hey Dylan you want to be dorm mates
you're like the only Gryffindor I know
in our community Dylan
oh man
you gotta be Gryffindor and you have to
be male to be dorm mates and I think you
can only have up to
I think it's four total so like
you're one you know you count as one and
then three other people
I think is how it works we'll find out
here
we shall find out shortly welcome in
everybody Welcome in
dude this game is gonna be a copyright
nightmare I feel like because as soon as
it starts
it's like hedwig's theme
WB please
um
smile down upon me and not flag these
videos
um
all right I saw let's see Ginny is the
first name I saw today Dylan is here Mr
Keys what's up Mr Keys do you finally
get that last uh last boss
it's not easy dude it is definitely not
easy in lies of P that final boss is
tough
Christy in the house welcome in Christy
how's it going good to see you good to
see you
who else we got we got elwin in the
house what is up elwin welcome in
Ryan De La Cruz Ryan how's it going
Alicia with the eight months of being a
member right here
at youtube.com retro raconteur I kind of
just started the intro as the starting
soon is still going so
maybe I should wait and do that till
we're on screen I can go ahead and say
hello to everybody though right right
Anna what's up Anna welcome in Pablo
how's it going Pablo it is here
yes indeed it is here worldwide launch
no matter where you're at no matter
where you're playing my friend
no matter where you are playing
Bean towns uh what's up Bean towns
oh yeah I mean you know James and I got
to be playing on launch Dave
that's what that's what multiple tabs
are for you know multiple windows
[Music]
there we go
hello everybody Welcome in
to Retro raconteur live some more
gameplay
and playing Harry Potter magic Awakening
for the first time I waited man I forced
myself I didn't want to do any of the
play tests I didn't want to make
accounts where I could play in different
countries and I didn't want to do all
that I just wanted to wait for the
official launch
[Music]
something
in my mouth there I wanted to wait for
the official launch and now it's here it
is here and I am super excited to be
playing it with you guys who knows maybe
James and I will uh link up and play
later I don't know what he's got going
on he might be playing with a bunch from
his community but you know I'd love to
play with James at some point but yeah
Beantown that's that's why that's why
they made multiple tabs you know you can
you can have both of us going and pulled
up
but I appreciate you guys all for being
here appreciate you all for the support
by the way for anyone who wants to play
on PC this is big this just kind of came
together in the past few days but
there's an emulator called BlueStacks if
you guys remember I've been talking
before about I'd been struggling to get
the emulator to work properly
um but we are actually uh partnering
with BlueStacks we're a BlueStacks
affiliate so if you hit exclamation
point blue Stacks in the chat and you
download using uh my affiliate link
there that will help me out the
program's free and this is like nothing
Shady or anything it's not like you're
breaking any kind of terms of service
but essentially what it is doing is it
allows you to run Android the Android
operating system on your Windows PC and
I think it actually works for Mac as
well
um so yeah and that's how I'm gonna be
playing the game today we're going to be
playing on BlueStacks uh there's a lot
of steps you have to go through to make
sure your PC is set up I'm going to be
making a video on that later a lot of
people have been asking for that
because um I mean there are there are
some hoops you have to jump through uh
basically you have to set up your
computer to enable what they call
virtualization
don't freak out don't panic I know it's
like it sounds like a big complicated
word but um there are a few steps you
have to jump through to enable if you
just Google like whatever version of
Windows you're on and then enable
virtualization you'll find some
instructions on how to do that and
BlueStacks actually I think they have
some
some tutorials on their website as well
um so yeah exclamation point BlueStacks
we're an affiliate with them it'd be
great if you guys could support again
the program is free so it's you download
it and you guys are gonna see it here
running uh right now on my screen but
basically what it allows you to do is uh
you're just it's like you're just
running Android so you can download any
Android game you will need like a Google
Play account or something
now also if you have one of the newer M1
Max so when Apple started making their
own chips if you have a Mac that has a
an M1 or higher chip
then you don't even need an emulator
because all of those Macs can actually
run iPhone or iPad apps directly on your
Mac I was trying it earlier on my laptop
um so that I mean all you have to do is
you go into your app store search for
Harry Potter magic awaken it won't come
up at first but then there's a little
like a little text a little button where
you have to shift it to iPhone or iPad
apps and it'll be in there really cool
really straightforward really easy now
there is also going to be an official PC
client at some point I saw the official
HP magic awake and Twitter respond to
somebody and they said yes it's coming
but they didn't have a date or anything
so those are the ways you can play or
you know you can also play on your phone
if that's what you choose to do or your
uh or your tablet of course so iPhone
iPad Android those are all the ways you
can play so again I'm using BlueStacks
that's how I'm going to be able to
stream it I'm going to show you guys my
screen over here
and then
yeah then I'll just be capturing
capturing that screen so
in fact you know what let's go ahead and
uh switch over to the view here I can
show you guys what it looks like
foreign
so there you go so you can see like
right now it's gonna have ads over here
on the left okay look at that an ad for
YouTube premium you can't make that up
YouTube premium dude it is it is
seriously amazing not sponsored on that
one but then over here on the right so
like once you're running BlueStacks like
let me just show you like see this is
just this is just running in a window on
my computer there's the BlueStacks app
right there
but if I hit this little button right
here to take it full screen
then it just gets rid of all the ads
gets rid of everything on the side now
I'm hoping that there's some way
I was playing a little bit of a Harry
Potter puzzles and spells last night
I'm hoping there's a way to like disable
all of this because I don't actually
I don't actually want all of that on
screen I'm sure there probably is right
all right let me get caught up with chat
and then we're gonna hop in and start
playing man
can't you change the server at the main
menu yeah I think the server is right
here mine is uh opal eye is what James
told me to uh to be on
Jenny you're making a second character
anyone on the mooncalf server yeah I
think the servers are all based on your
location I believe
but I guess you can choose I actually
don't know that that one that's what uh
James sent me a message saying to join
that one and then as soon as I popped
open my my game for the first time
that's that's what was already up so I'm
just sticking with that hold on I'm
gonna turn on my big light here too you
guys can't
usually during the day the light from
that window is enough but today the I
guess it's a little cloudy outside
wasn't coming through very good
thank you
Mike Mike and Nation
welcome welcome how's it going Gigi is a
lobster in the house how's it going GG
good to see you
you're playing the game right now let's
go
yeah you cannot have mixed dorms Anna
yep you gotta be uh same house same
gender to be to be in the dorm and it's
only like four I think
NP welcome in moonlace how's it going
moonlace
let's see developer in the house there's
Paula how's it going Paula Mr Case
you'll get it dude you'll get it
stick with it stick with it Elwyn with
the nine months what a day indeed to
have the nine month anniversary let's go
that is awesome thank you so much Elwyn
for the nine months of support look at
that Chrissy it's been nine months too
no way
both of you started uh became members
the very same month that's awesome
nine months
what do you guys think does it feel
longer I feel like it feels long like I
feel like it's been years since we've
been hanging out and doing this
how do you download Pablo which uh which
platform are you on it is in both the uh
iOS so it's on the Apple App Store and
it's in the Google Play Store as well
it is officially on both of them
hey shubham not sure if I'm pronouncing
that correctly but yes it does indeed
thank you so much for stopping by hello
world I played this game for a few hours
art style is amazing I don't
Ash Winder server hey that's why I'm
looking forward to playing because then
you guys know we're gonna be cranking
out the how-to videos so the first video
I'm going to work on is uh to explain to
you guys how to set all this up how to
get everything up and running here
you're shocked why you shocked Pablo
today's the day dude today is the day
let's go ahead and move our cam up a
little bit too although I don't know
where all the UI elements are going to
be in this game but yeah whoever said
they love the art style I'm right there
with you it's I know it seems to be a
little bit you know some people don't
really like it to him I love it man I
think it's great I love just like a
different it's like a different take
on The Wizarding World so I love for
something like this to exist alongside
something like Hogwarts Legacy which is
like you know that more realistic look
and then here you have something that's
more kind of artistic I I think I think
it's great to have both of them but yeah
this type of game not normally the type
of game I would play I like MMOs
um I was a big fan of
Destiny played that for a long time so
we'll see man we'll see what I think
about the core gameplay Loop if I enjoy
it then I mean it could be a game that I
I play for a while you know
Anna you're at work so you haven't had
much time to play yet
jzt what's up dude welcome back
you have BlueStacks nice and yeah that's
I tried some others and I can never get
them to work properly this is the first
one that I could get to uh to work
properly so
all the command is not working okay hold
on let me see if we can get the command
working if you if you can't get the
command working you can check the video
description so I do have the link in
there as well but let me see if I uh
I might have forgotten the last step on
the command
thank you for catching that moderators
appreciate it let me see here
let me go into our chat bot
maybe uh
yeah I get I think stream elements just
hasn't
isn't awake yet for some reason
is the the command should be enabled
actually I don't think any of the
commands are working right now
but yeah if you guys just look in the
video description or mods if you just
want to like copy and paste that
basically that first line of the live
stream description if anybody asks about
because I expect that's going to be a
question that we're getting a lot
throughout the day is how are you
playing this on PC
hello world that depends on where which
region you're in
um in terms of if the official like PC
client to where you can just download
the game is out it will come to the US
and the UK at some point but they
haven't said win so
this is uh this is how you do it
right now
that's right Mr Keys yeah Google Play
has like a beta which I don't know if
this game's on there I did try that out
a few weeks ago as well to see how that
that would work
and there I tried to find like Harry
Potter Hogwarts mystery and I couldn't
find it on there so I don't know but
they could be adding things to that as
well
Robo Panda thank you so much for the
tier one Robo Panda appreciate it
yeah if you if you guys have one of the
newer Macs I'm seeing some people like
post the date of their Mac if you have
one of the newer Macs it it's awesome it
just uh it can run any IOS app
out of the box pretty cool Sheena how's
it going Sheena good to see you Cloud
Roth
super busy wanted to stop by and say
hello Cloud Roth good to see you
appreciate you stopping by and Robo
Panda thank you so much for the tier one
King of the North just downloaded it
nice
Moon lace with the two months uh
thank you so much
appreciate that moonlace appreciate that
oh no Elwyn says there were issues with
streaml yeah stream elements was just
like yo we're not here today
so no commands today apparently
there you go Ellen's got it posted in
the chat though
thank you so much Ellen appreciate it
Paula hey that's how to do it Paula
that's how to do it
Anna your Mac has the M1 oh it's a work
computer ah
oh dude everybody's having issues with
stream elements no way
Psy as soon as I you know remember the
moderators remember back when Hogwarts
Legacy released we had that period where
it was like nightbot and stream elements
were both we were trying to use both of
them
and then I I just said okay we're gonna
use stream elements for twitch nightbot
for YouTube
and then just recently I was like you
know what all this has been working so
well she balance has been doing great
let's just stick with stream elements
and look look look what happens
look what happens now
oh of course Patrick what's up dude
welcome in
Patrick man how's the new job been going
dude
uh wautz or woot w-o-u-t it is it is out
today today is the release day Global
release it is available everywhere
everywhere everywhere everywhere in the
world
on iOS or Android
today we're using the BlueStacks app to
play it on my PC so we are a BlueStacks
affiliate but there's a number of
emulators you could use it's not like a
doesn't break terms of service or
anything basically you're just it allows
you to run Android on your computer so
that is how we're gonna be playing it
today
which dude
I wonder when the PC client officially
comes out would we be able to take our
progress over because this is all tied
to my Google Play account so I'm
guessing if I made one on my Mac it'd be
like a completely different account
all right so here's what I'm gonna do
I'm going to go ahead and turn off the
music
and then we're going to be jumping in
for the first time so man I guess I
should go ahead and enable the music but
WB please we're playing your game no no
copyright don't take down the stream
all right let's see
all right chat let me know if that's is
that too loud or or just right I'm Gonna
Leave it right here
for the game volume so yeah all I did to
if you guys actually download and try
out BlueStacks you just hit Escape
and so then over here on the right you
have all these tools so there's one
right there where you can adjust the
volume
oh there it is
all right so let's see inter Hogwarts
man I think we're ready let me see what
this is first though log in okay we
definitely do not want to have a guest
account
all right let's see does it show you my
password oh it does okay hold on
hold on let me hide this for a second
all right
let me hide this for one moment
oh you can log in later nah I want to
get those rewards Anna we got to get
those rewards which we we managed to hit
the highest tier I don't know if you
guys saw that
that uh for all of the little in-game
rewards that you can redeem by doing the
pre-sale all right let's see WB
I don't even know my passwords guys I
use a password manager I recommend it
for everybody
but because of that I don't actually
know any except for my like master
password that's the only one I actually
know
okay where is that
see there's some some uh characters I
don't even know where they're at on the
keyboard
but I definitely recommend it it is like
it's kind of annoying at times but it is
definitely way more secure
all right dude we're in we're in let me
go ahead and let me see if there's
anything else we need to do on that yes
WB Games account is linked
nice all right what is this for here
okay all good we can switch it back now
Draco what's up
none of the emulators are working we're
on BlueStacks right now it seems to be
working pretty well so far we're not in
game
but so far so good
no no I don't want you guys hacking my
WB account okay welcome to Hogwarts
Harry Potter magic wig is now available
worldwide explore Hogwarts with your
friends enjoy an all new immersive story
discover wonders in the Forbidden Forest
battle in multiplayer duels and more
okay key updates earn up to 30 Ruby Keys
see we don't even know all these terms
yet like what they're used for and
everything
wait by the way did anybody say
what's the is the volume good for you
guys the volume like on the game
I don't want it to be too loud
okay so we can get 30 Ruby keys by
completing yearbook stories between one
one and two one this event Ruby key
rewards will be an ongoing event for all
players and will continue until all
event rewards are claimed
complete yearbook stories up to 2-1
July 4th okay so that's like about a
week
yeah it's part of the global launch week
celebration
baby ant padian opal eye and whomping
willow cards have increased earn rate
oh man see I don't I don't know if these
if these are good or not all right I'm
not gonna read all these
I'm not gonna read all these we haven't
played the game I feel like this would
be more
important if you're someone who'd been
playing the game excuse me
uh we definitely want English
this client will now attempt to sell for
pay oh no no we don't want to do
anything with that we're good there
okay and we're on opal I let's let's
enter guys let's go
you skipped see Anna I'm just like I
always like I look through every option
before I start games it's just a habit
volume is pretty good I want it to be
perfect GG is it is it too loud or do we
need to we need to boost it a little bit
[Music]
because I'm I'm happy to turn it up or
turn it down if we need to
oh the update notes volume is good okay
all right guys
time to enter Hogwarts
that's right Patrick you gotta be
thorough by selecting accept okay I'm
gonna go we're gonna read all of these
right now guys
okay and we've read them
if you guys did you guys see me read
them I read them
we pulled it up did you not see me pull
up the list I've always
been use headphones for the best explain
it I feel like it's slow down
it doesn't bother me not anymore I'm
used to the stairs The Whispers but I
wish I didn't have to hide who I am I
wish there was a place where I belong
what was that
rubius hagra keeper of keys and games
and Hogwarts
who are you
Ruby is hot I need to go up a bit more
because it's a little low for me you're
only here to deliver this
ah this is for you
oh here we go
we'll play on 7th gen iPad if you just
go to the uh the App Store and search
for the game it should tell you if
you're if yours will support it or not
we are pleased to inform you that you
have been accepted at Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry
all right so we're gonna be retro
sign your name and return this slip to
the owl
protect your privacy do not use personal
information such as your real name okay
name already exists
no all right who who stole it what Punk
stole it from us
but wait isn't that me because I already
set up
I already set up my my name
oh no
oh stream elements is stream elements is
running now yes let's go finally
when did YouTube
wait is it running ads in the lives
oh man it might be a new it might be a
new setting that I need to disable
let me see if I can actually
all caps
does that matter
oh he took that yes
no it's stuttering
no
oh no
this feels so weird though like I'm
gonna have to like hold this
okay Enter Hogwarts the accept
well dude that actually control okay
that's pretty cool
all right here we go guys we're about to
get the
we're about to get the news that retro
is taken
and the experience was Unforgettable
looks like I drove a little too fast
too fast actually doesn't look too bad
on screen what you guys are seeing
whoa
oh wait so we're already
I I don't know did our WB account link
up
dude I think it did
oh my gosh that's clutch man so wait
that means you can go between
wait wait which one do we tap here
that one that one
I don't want to jinx anything but if
we're retro with all caps then that
means it just it just automatically
pulled it in
foreign
I guess I could actually watch
I have the game being displayed on like
three screens right now it's kind of
crazy
I could just watch it being played up
here
okay let's take a look at your task
tracker metamalkin's new robe
have a makeover at Madame malkins all
right
tap to enter so we just tap on over here
to the right
I'll do that loading was quick
oh I'm just so happy we finally got it
working dude let's go let's go
75 minutes in
don't even care
all right you can alter your appearance
later for free witches and wizards
cannot share a dormitory so please
choose carefully
so these are just like little presets
here and then we
then we take it from there
not even sure how to describe what time
all right so that
uh I feel like I'm closer to this I hope
I don't end up looking silly this guy
oh wait this isn't where we set our
change our character
or is this what we're about to do
yeah here we go
all right
okay
dude is it all
long hair options no way right
I need something that suits my style
okay so these are it says accessories
wait how do I go back
[Music]
so is this it is it just like these
presets
yeah yeah not only do I have the game
running we've got a great story that's
true
you can change your face okay so you do
that
not at this screen right
I think I have to go I have to confirm
and go on over
all right dude you got to be kidding me
with these to look good for school
perhaps are changes in order
well I guess we're gonna have to be like
16 year old retro
when I had a lot more hair than I do now
let's go
that one that's kind of how I used to
style my hair actually
yeah
and
definitely wasn't black yeah kind of
like a dark
[Music]
yeah go with the dark brown
no bald eleven I mean they're no like
closely shaven you know
okay so this is a skin
[Music]
okay so that's controlling the face
right there all right so that's option
one
option two
option three
option four
that option four I feel like I'll let
you guys help me chat what which one you
think looks most like me
definitely not that one
oh definitely not and then that's the
last one not that one either I mean none
of them look like exactly like me but I
feel like that might be closest right
this this is option four
no beards no way it's Hogwarts Legacy
all over again okay so let's go through
them there's one
two
three
four which is the one that I I'm
personally leaning to five
six
seven
eight
nine
and then ten perhaps are changes in
order
that's five
Roger said five
so that's five
that's four yeah the lips are bigger on
that one but the nose I feel like this
one matches my nose better
this one matches my lips better
oh dude I need something
another four
Jared says five oh man
all right well we're all in I agree
these are definitely like the two
closest
another four Lauren with a four
I'm gonna go with four
all right that for hair
okay yeah eyes are blue
perhaps are changes in order
oh wait what is this this is where you
change oh you can actually change your
eyebrows this is just the color okay
I need something that suits my style
pupil pattern what doesn't look like we
have any other options on that one right
now
okay this is like uh
freckles moles okay no on that
and then glasses nah
oh although if I did Rock with glasses I
would pick that one I do wear glasses
sometimes but
majority of time I don't all right
confirm
I was wondering that Jenny if if there
were more options later on
oh
maybe I should go okay for me definite
no on that one
[Music]
definite no on that one I'm either
number one or number three
that's number one
that's number three
I think we go with number three oh Roger
said one
Lauren said one all right all right all
right we'll go with one we'll let the
let Chad help us out
shall we oh no then we had three threes
it's all good
shop is very close you'll see okay I
already did go on and get my wand though
so I wonder if it's gonna
it's gonna automatically pull that
wants from ollivanders uh task complete
time to check out your next task
oh dude this is crazy
feels so weird controlling it with my
phone I never play mobile games
yeah I see Hagrid over there but what
you guys got to realize is I like to
explore I like to look around in games
where's revelio do we have revelio yet
I need lots of revelio
you guys who played the game are just
like retro go there's nothing to find
please just go
just go talk to Hagrid oh wait who is
that
okay no look look see see I bet I can
talk to these people look at this
yeah see there we go Dylan
holdren
but a good one
all right and was there somebody else I
could talk to yeah you hey you look I
think we
I think this is an important student
oh dude that's Ivy over there
we just don't know their names yet in
game
oh my gosh I wish I could play this with
a controller
wait you can actually connect your your
PS5 controller
to a an iPhone
but I don't dare risk that given all
that we've all that it's taken to get
this set up
by Nana
probably worried about me getting lost
again
I hope Mr Ollivander knows what's wrong
with my wand oh it's working interesting
a few days ago
and this is like the Draco Malfoy like
character
I'll try that off stream right
see if we can get that working there
all right Hagrid I guess we'll finally
talk to you buddy robes have you
it's time to get you oh it looked it
actually looks so good
I really do wish I could use controller
because it looks so good on my on my
monitor but having to focus on this
all right let's see discuss wands with
Haggard before entering the shop one
you're one sweat
all right you ready
[Music]
see I already did the one thing online
another young I didn't like the one that
I got so if it gives us a different one
I'm not gonna complain
I agree Eagle I really do like it I
think it's great
[Music]
this is a different wand
Phoenix Feather is my core though this
is closer to what I have on Wizarding
World
anyway
apparently not
no
one I want him
try out this one dang it
okay we got another Phoenix Feather
Grapevine 13 inches flexibility supple
let me guess it's also gonna fail
no no oh my
[Music]
the first one we tried that would be a
great plot twist it would indeed
yeah this is not the one that I got when
I went on the website so I
I don't know what that's pulling from
but hey it's all good
I am happy with this one
oh hello
it connected to the it connected to the
Android one no way
see we have retro in all caps right
there
okay
all right now that everything's seems to
be working properly I think I can
finally relax a bit here
I just don't know where to put my hands
because I'm having to sit it on my table
here
combination
Ivy is the big bad just like poppy no
way
that's what my Nana said she taught me a
few spells but
but I can't do them anymore could there
be something wrong with my wand
would you be so kind as to demonstrate
young Miss why are we here watching this
laughs
curious very curious
monster book
allow me my friend
I don't know what I'm doing but
MP replenishes over time okay we've got
three right now
they look tough be careful okay
now my wand is at uh four MP inflatus
can help you control them
oh we just got our first card combat
actions are represented by cards play
cards to cast spells summon creatures
and wield powerful magical objects
your deck can contain potent spells
including those favored by Infamous dark
Wizards
using a card requires MP alright so
looks like it's gonna cost three I'm
assuming and we've got four right now
oh that's cool
boom brilliantly done
and then I guess he kind of has like
this auto spell that he's just sort of
casting here tap on the ground
to move moving requires movement cards I
don't have movement cards
okay we just got 30 of them
okay so I can move 29 times incendio is
a good choice when facing multiple
opponents
all right we just got an incendio card
and it wants us to put it right in the
middle there
oh dude that's awesome
careful they're coming right at you
all right let's hit him with an inflatus
so I wonder if that MP just continuously
replenishes or what
Victory our first Victory let's go
well done
done I haven't seen a young
whistle almost looks like a game ad what
do you mean Dylan
I'm not following I haven't seen a young
Witcher wizard take to their wand that
quickly since
I remember everyone I've ever sold Mr
Potter
thanks I couldn't have done it without
your help
hopefully now I won't make a fool of
myself when I get to Hogwarts
you're going to Hogwarts
I'm Ivy Warrington by the way Ivy
Warrington there we go
dude I hate that my name is all capital
but
it is what it is man
retro lower case was already taken
oh I see what you mean
card collection 5 out of 75 that is an
epic card Ventus
shoots forth a powerful Gust in a
straight line knocking back enemies
along its path and dealing damage deals
200 additional damage to Shields
[Music]
monster book of monsters okay that one's
a rare card throws a copy of the monster
book of Monsters the book will Sprint
towards the Target location knocking
back all opponents hit along the way
then begin attacking
atmospheric charm
rare cast of thunderstorm that damages a
single random opponent within its range
each time it strikes applies a heel
reduction effect to units hit
so does everybody get the same first
three cards
were they different
tap to continue
alright I'll post discuss owls with
Hagrid before adopting one oh let's go
we get to go get an owl oh wait Ivy you
have something else to say
if my wand is fine then maybe something
about me did change
oh what
I don't remember anything
do I hmm
foggy dude someone casts a memory charm
on her maybe hi ivy did you get your
wand sorted
same cards gotcha
I think so yes thanks again for your
help
my pleasure
all right Hagrid thought I'd get you a
gift Venus you're new to Magic an owl is
mighty useful
you do like owls don't you of course you
do oh yeah
do we get to pick one though yes
let's go dude
hello
whoa look at this guy oh yes he's quite
fond of you I couldn't decide on an owl
so he left it up to you to choose
go on then have a look for yourself
no I didn't mean to do that
okay wait just three choices
no way right
okay we've got the Scopes owl
are small in size and known
for their agility they also have strong
Raptor like claws to catch prey
then we have the brown fish owl brown
fish owls like their privacy and often
live alone near a water source although
they appear to struggle while it's
flying they are actually powerful Flyers
that are fast and silent
oh
and then the barred owl the Curious
barred owl is easily distinguishable
from other owls thanks to the extensive
horizontal and vertical bars on its
plumage is it plumage
plumage
and an unusual trilled hoot
[Music]
number three oh man you guys are all
thrown out
hello world says the tiny owl Dylan says
the third one
I kind of like the description of this
one the best
I like that it's it's like a silent
and fast flyer
I'm gonna go with this one
nobody was saying that one so I want to
go with that one want to come with me
come home with me
Dylan said I admit number two
sure you did
brown fish owl owl number one oh can you
get more owls as you go along
all right talk to Hagrid in Diagon Alley
okay I'm kind of I'm trying to like get
good at doing this without
looking at my at my phone
let's take a closer look at my at my
what my task tracker got everything you
need
yeah yeah I know what I'm supposed to do
it's the first time in Diagon Alley you
can walk around a bit more thank you
Hagrid yes I would I would like to look
around dude can you like oh you can move
the camera around let's go
so I don't think can I go into any of
the other shops or anything probably not
right
who are you my name's Robin
pleasure to meet you Robin
oh I was like as waiting is he actually
gonna say
my name is retro I like quidditch or do
you love it
I don't really know much about Quidditch
what are you
sorry you
earlier oh you can meet all the other
first-year students let's go
Merlin's beard
all right so let's see let's walk around
see who else we can meet here
all right so it's blocked right there
locked right there all right
so we already met two of the other oh
dude can we go back here
nope okay
all right so yeah I'm kind of getting a
feel for the game I didn't really know
sort of what the structure was in terms
of how much it would or wouldn't allow
you to explore
Sports
yes I am I suppose you want to know my
name too
it's Daniel
Daniel page Daniel page okay if you
don't mind I'm kind of busy so
see that way
sure
dude check out the mustache right here
hold on
go this way
look at this guy
look at that stash
wow all right I said hello to you but
you did not tell me your name
Kevin Farrell at your service
for what it's worth
sorry roller Panda which uh which house
are you it's not
it's not because I think it depends on
house house and uh gender
yeah yep thank you moonlace that's right
same server same house same gender
Dylan who else we got man we gotta find
some other uh we gotta find some fellow
gryffindors
I suppose you want to know my name fine
Sandra bull happy Cassandra vole
yes I'm pleased to meet you Cassandra
free one is
are you going to Hogwarts
my name has been on the list for ages
generic mean girl our Draco Malfoy right
here
they actually said that's who they uh
she's kind of modeled after after Malfoy
a little bit
all right anybody else oh dude we got
several students right here
hello oh are you twins
no way we got twins too Mom just double
Charmed me so she can have persons
oh my gosh we deserve that I'm not gonna
lie man he deserved that I'm for sure
he's called me up or is it the other way
around
could one Fisher dude that is that is
totally a thing that people we just say
it though right it's like you're trying
to be polite but it's the most dumb
obvious question so you guys twins
no
no I actually don't even know this guy I
I don't know we just we happen to meet
online people said we looked at like
Lottie Turner okay hello Lottie
yes I can't you have to oh I didn't mean
to skip that one
you want to paint me what
um all right I've never been painted
before can't say that I have
it's easy just sit very still oh I can
use a freezing charm if it helps
all right man I gotta say I'm loving the
personality of the students already that
that's really fun
okay is there anybody else that we need
to meet
oh yeah you're Ivy right do you have
anything else to say amazing
oh yes although I can't remember the
last time
it's odd isn't it feed me like one of
your French girls oh my gosh Craig what
is that from dude what is that from
she's so forgetful today I think that's
a clue man somebody is somebody is
messed with her memory
or she's poly Juiced she's actually
someone else
okay we already said I think we got
everybody
all right let's go Hagrid
oh dude look there's the the Weasley's
got everything you need
Titanic Oh my gosh
how could I forget that she must be
excited to go to Hogwarts don't worry
you'll get there soon
all right we're ready Hagrid
we already
before I knew it it was time to go to
school
this year Frey and Cole their last
name's Frey the frey twins
oh this is kind of cool they introduce
you to all of them
one more time here
oh my gosh dude look at this
all right uh find a seat okay
you already know if we try to sit by
Cassandra no way she's gonna let us
right
no way she would let us actually sit by
her but I'm gonna try it I I feel like I
have to try
let's see if it will if if she'll let us
excuse me may I sit here
this is gonna be a big time no
I knew it
all right what about uh Lonnie
the seat
she's the artist right
she's gonna start trying to paint us
right here
they're trying to force you let's see
who are they forcing us to sit by yeah
yeah all right fine Lottie fine
OH Ivy okay
[Music]
of course stormy welcome in
the monster a card next to her
how do I how do I get it are we talking
about like a wizard card I saw the
wizard card yeah I'm a little nervous
actually Jake what's up just got to
Hogwarts nice I probably would have been
there already if not for uh
we had a few issues getting everything
going at the beginning oh here we go
dude
the first years going across the lake
is Hagrid singing to them
who's that singing
[Music]
welcome to Hogwarts when I first became
headmistress barely full Jake thank you
for the 10 months dude appreciate it
gonna be playing at work
to the combined oh this is cool
the Knights of Hogwarts man such evil
but should challenges arise know that
together you are capable of much more
than you might think
now to those feeling overwhelmed by the
occasion remember that even Harry Potter
once stood where Harry Potter
look at Dumbledore and Snape
difficult very difficult
like would you I would watch a whole
movie in this art style man
I think it'd be so cool
we must see to
see I agreed and I agree this is very
important as your house will be akin to
your family while you are at Hogwarts
they will share your triumphs and your
failures is everyone ready yes all right
form a line
after that the Sorting began proper
proper
one by one students were sorted into
their houses and where is he going it
was my turn oh it didn't tell us
oh my gosh is that is that Sprout back
there
animation when you get the legendary
card is so cool
yeah Dylan
I agree
where shall I put you
and where shall I put you do they ask
questions or do we just picked
I see
yep
and just a hint of tenacity excellent
no
not half above
what
reconsider
let me take no I'm not unsure I'm very
sure
interesting yeah it seems totally random
interesting
there we go
is that you
best be sure
I'm sure hat
oh my goodness you have to confirm it so
many times are you sure you want to join
Gryffindor you can only share a dorm
room with students from the same house
yep
boom
there we go
Gryffindor
oh sorry I kind of stole your thunder
there hat
I think mine sounded more forceful with
feeling you know
didn't seem very excited for me hat I
don't appreciate it
Ivy does anyone know what happened to
Ivy we created three new characters and
got all ravenclaws I see Hagrid oh
there's Neville up there dude
party is in order it appears we have
lost
she's already gotten lost
what no way
I can't believe Ivy has gone missing
oh dude I didn't realize
I mean I knew a little bit about the
story
okay Ivy probably just took a wrong turn
trouble seems to follow that girl should
I go look for her
I mean yeah should I go look for her she
helped me in the wand shop so now it's
my turn to help her
you just found her
if there's still no news of her tomorrow
I'll have to go look for her
I'm exhausted I can't believe so much
has happened
what
oh just automatically
here we go no roommates okay join a
house
at the Sorting ceremony we already did
that but why is there a little like
present oh
task complete
what do we get for that knapsack
what do we get
popularity zero
come on
exploration attributes oh this is
interesting
decks I probably don't have anything yet
right except for those yeah the two
cards that we got
Social Club nothing yet all right all
right
you sent me a friend request oh man how
do I accept it
and do we have like a limit
because I need to add all you guys
is it under info somewhere
if only you could get a beard yeah yeah
if only the 11 year olds could have
beards
let's take a look at the common room
here
wait where did the uh they had the
Gryffindor oh it's only on oh it's
because I don't have any dorm mates yet
That's why nothing else
is taken over there
yo Dylan
let's go accepted you right there Dylan
dorm details oh let's take a look at
this
okay so this is where you would get your
roommates
offline dueling Club dormitory hope I'm
not blocking too much now we're good uh
dueling Club dormitory dance club
outside story class Forbidden Forest
diagonally quidditch and then offline
dorm request yeah Dylan we need to set
that up and find some other
find some other gryffindors
maybe it's a little gear icon down here
let's see privacy basic gameplay actions
social
oh my gosh dude this is gonna be so cool
playing with all you guys in here
personal information
allow the sale or sharing of my personal
info
for California residents only
no way not a California resident but
I mean
I'll turn it off
hide my information from strangers
I probably should enable that right if
I'm going to be streaming the game a lot
friends from personal space
yeah let's let's turn that on for now
only my only friends can see my decks I
don't care about that block all
Spectators I don't care about that
notice board from strangers
I don't know enough about that yet
trying to send me a dorm request right
now
yeah I wonder if it's uh maybe it's like
the user Center over here nope not that
wait what is download redeem
Brooks how's it going
yeah how did you even send it Dylan like
just so I can uh know how to do it
oh my God
oh wait maybe it was right there hold on
if I go back to the info
and then over here this little wizard
right here
wait is that you Ginny
that's you let's go all right
except
oh oh my goodness
Darth jar jar which one of you is that
man
who is Darth jar jar all right let's see
if we can find James
did he use expecto go
like that
oh that's definitely him
right that's for sure him isn't it
I'm gonna request him introduce yourself
hi I'm retro
here this this way he'll know it's me
I'm gonna say
yo
it's your boy
retro
is that alias
is that required
I guess that's just what he'll see I
don't know
[Music]
oh the alien the Alias is for me wait
what do you mean for like what I see on
his name
oh it can be changed okay okay good good
good
all right who else Draco you said
just d-r-a-k-o
search
oh my gosh wait how come it let's oh you
can have
oh that's interesting so you can have
the same name as long as they're on
different servers
all right is this you Draco the opal eye
one
or Draco lower case
you did you had you spelled yours with
capital D and then r-a-k-o
oh yeah yeah here we go here we go the
requests are coming in
shoot man as long as there's not a limit
I'll I'll just uh I'll add all you guys
JW I bet that's Jake
yep I saw your message there
you were you were the one with the hat
okay
okay that is crazy
Robo panda look at that you just
immediately popped up
under recent
I don't even know what Alias is I'm not
gonna do anything with alias
all right let's find Draco again he said
the one with the hat
thank you
search
okay it's Gotta Be an opal eye one right
oh yeah this one that's the one you mean
the hat and the little icon right
oh my gosh why did it take me out
could not find this oh drank
typo hello
[Music]
there we go
150 Limit Oh
oh my
all right then like where do I see all
you guys
like where do I see the the full list of
who I have as my friend
I wonder if Ben or Lynette have set
theirs up yet I know Lynette's like
doing some
spending some time offline at the moment
cannot find this player okay
what does Ben usually do he's like I'm
Ben snow
oh dang it
oh you got to get a little bit farther
before you see everything okay
all right
I think we're good for now
we'll add all you guys later I'll add as
many of you that that come through
follow your classmate to the charms
classroom all right
let's go dude
come on you don't want to be late for
your first class this is Daniel man
relax dude
just relax Daniel
changing your school ropes well Daniel
like
you're not helping me here buddy
new mirror look okay tap select your
house robes
you're all done okay that's it that's
all we had to do
nice let's go look changed successfully
all right now are we good
oh my gosh you guys I'm sorry about the
ads I didn't think it would be
think it would be that many
Roger I think it's a new YouTube setting
that I I enabled before the start of
stream but
if it's doing uh that many I'll make
sure to uh
keep it turned off next time
keep up might be lost hold on John's
classroom should be just
wrong way
and portraits have the patience
to point us the way
[Music]
I'm just fixing my my webcam up there
all right
three times oh my God
oh my God okay let's see here follow
your classmate to the charms classroom
okay
oh dude there's actually other people in
here
oh this is crazy man
[Music]
Rob Smith what up Rob
I know I'm supposed to be following that
guy but I'm just oh no oh
we messed up
can we wait come on stairs come on back
please
mind the staircases they like to change
all right what do we have right here
Cecil Shetland ouch get your finger off
me don't you have anything better to do
all right fine
we got Rob Smith right there jazz
Jasmine them
[Music]
dude this is crazy that you can just
can see and interact with people right
in here oh this is the charms classroom
all right
dude we're gonna have to find we're
gonna have to look up who the uh the
lower case retro is and be like come on
dude
how are you gonna do that to us
Waldo
so these are like other these are like
real people in here right now right
Fernando
like can I can I go up and interact with
you
you can't talk or anything
like what if I what if I tap on
oh you can just see them running around
I mean that that alone is still pretty
cool
but I wish you could interact somehow
maybe I just haven't unlocked it yet
all right flip quick
Swish and flick
s Chloe it should just be retro all caps
yes professor
like that right there you see on my
where it says yes Professor just above
that
one of the most famous Wizards
a stroll in his first year
and he did it with none other than this
charm protecting his friends when
Guardians
they are real people that's so cool
is it is it Rion or is it Ryan r-i-o-n
how do you pronounce that Ryan stop
playing to watch me hey thanks for
watching appreciate you being here
hanging out actually all you guys that
are here right now man thanks everybody
oh no oh no I really need to pay
attention okay wait use vintus to blow
it away
oh I love how it shows you the little
path right there
oh he got a hit in on me though
okay can we move let's move over here oh
it's kind of guiding me through this
battle okay the monster book of monsters
can charge at opponents from a distance
look the troll is distracted by the
monster book of monsters all right
now is the time to strike back
the atmospheric charm deals heavy single
Target damage
oh that's cool
your next card is shown here
oh wait am I like M I'm in the battle
now
I probably shouldn't have moved over
there but
let's try inflate us
there we go
okay so I'm down to eight move cards
all right let's try let's try this one
again that seemed to work pretty well
I don't understand what they meant by
the new card
like how do I
oh I see it now then it moves over
gotcha
William how's it going welcome in
yeah you unlock you can you can duel
each other Jay that's right
you can duel there's like a whole PVP
system
okay first clear Rewards
spiders oh my goodness we got the
spiders card
use this card to summon a cluster of
spiderlings no way
and then we got some gold
acromantula Venom and troll a troll
summon
oh then it's gonna it's gonna tell me
here what we got anyway all right
all right all right all right
oh and then you have like the DPS
numbers down here
attack range medium damage interval 2.3
oh my goodness man so this is gonna get
this is gonna get really deep at high
level
there's gonna be a lot of nuance to this
there was a bottle of acromantula Venom
at the Target area dealing damage over
time
that I I see that could be pretty
powerful let's watch the tutorial video
oh wait didn't let me watch oh I wish I
was trying to click to watch the video
clear within 210 seconds complete we did
that nice
um I didn't turn the oh wait you think
that's what that meant Lauren do you
think that's what that was referring to
oh I just said hide my information from
strangers that's all
I don't even know what information that
is but
[Music]
Robin Kevin and Lottie talk to Robin I
know you
that's right we did Robin I'm so glad
you remembered
and you're
wrong yeah already back to the spiders
again
[Music]
joined can you join different servers I
think you have to make new accounts to
do that
Jenny I don't know if Jenny's still here
I think she was she would know about
that because she was having to make a
separate account I believe
foreign
it doesn't make you nervous being that
high
are you kidding it's amazing amazing
oh man I can't wait till we get to learn
the broom flight Anthony welcome in
wait what's going on with that feather
you must have practiced a lot not really
I'm just naturally okay you can join
different servers you oh you can using
the same account I wish I was that good
I'm sure you'll get that I did not know
that
you just have to like go back and forth
right I'm on the opal eye server that's
where I'm at practice
oh dueling Club if you like let's go
afraid
I'm ready for our dueling tutorial by
the way we already met I'll give it a
try
dude she didn't even remember us wow
wow she did not even remember us you
guys
talk to Cassandra then challenge her yes
let's go
Kenyan and Erica hello
so crazy man I love that we could just
you could see everybody in here
uh Draco or anybody else who's been
playing this game for a while anybody
know if this if it has controller
support
if I connect the controller to my iPhone
would it work
I'd love to play this with a controller
I feel like a lot of it's touch touch
heavy though
check your cards okay
this is your currently equipped deck
tap here to configure
this is the deck used in battle
here are the Spells you've already
learned drag them into your deck
okay so your deck is three six like
eight cards I guess that's what you
start with
all right so we'll put that one up here
put that one up here
that one up here
you build your first deck all right
now equipped Beatles burden I don't know
what that was
have you ever tried it
I'm I'm afraid to try it since it took
so long to get things working but
I'll definitely try it after the Stream
all right I'm ready to challenge her
nice Moon lace made a different one
or joined a different one all right talk
to Cassandra then Challenger
[Applause]
wait I don't need to change it I already
just set that up didn't I
okay my deck or match I think that's all
that I can do from right there
I thought we were dueling Cassandra
although summoning the troll requires a
high number of magic points it has a lot
of health and can withstand a lot of
damage on the front line
all right so they're still kind of
guiding us through all of these
all right so I wonder what that red
just showing us who he's gonna attack
oh and he put out the spiders no way but
see now we can't do anything I mean I
guess we could move like over here
your opponent Summit a swarm of spiders
the troll can only attack one unit at a
time and will be quickly overrun try
countering with acromantula Venom
wait acrimential of Venom on spiders
it works I guess it works oh now he's
gotta troll out no way this time your
opponent released a troll let's give
them a taste if they're on medicine and
use spiders to deal with the troll
okay
right there spiders
follow the spiders
all right now we actually have some more
things though
so let's see should I like run over here
oh no okay I think we're on our own now
oh my goodness
I think I think we're on our own
yeah let's let's get another troll out
all the trolls are fighting dude this is
crazy
let's get some more spiders out
oh can I move like can I get out of that
we can nice oh but it follows you
they almost got him
dude
I think I'm really gonna like this man
it's early it's early I haven't got to
like the micro transaction stuff yet but
I can see this battle system being
really fun
especially once you get to like some of
the higher level decks and stuff
[Music]
how is that fair that's what I'm saying
dude
oh she means that's what I'm saying two
against two
I'm on opolai yeah yeah you'll need a
partner
not a problem let's do this yeah Robin
all Robin's in Gryffindor too let's go
Robin's the Quidditch player right
yeah Robin's cool
Robin's like my first friend I feel like
except for Ivy but Ivy's currently
missing
oh my gosh we're just we're just in it
this time huh
they get the troll in right away to give
me that defense oh no that monster book
though man
can your spells Miss I wonder like if
you don't
let's get one on Cassandra right there
oh I didn't mean to move that
whoa wait what the heck is that crab and
Goyle out here
oh my gosh
oh they did man we just destroyed them
great teamwork Robin in retro
oh she is not happy
we met in the corridor we met my name is
he forgot too we met before that
Cassandra we bet before that
you know more than you Don still
defeating a Fray is nothing to get
excited about when you've improved I'll
duel you again if you're up for it oh
I'd like that we're up for it Cassandra
and I'll be ready we're up for it
yes
if you aim outside where the enemies are
at it'll Miss uh okay and they can walk
away from the attacks gotcha
yeah this is this is
we're early we're early but this is a
lot of fun
oh speaking of silver keys and gems and
all that anybody know how we
do you know how we claim all of the
Rewards or is that just automatic should
it just automatically show up somewhere
all of like the uh the pre-launch
rewards and that stuff
okay oh my gosh okay a lot of
information here dueling Club
top wizard best partners
witches of wizards can challenge one
another to real-time duels in the
dueling Club duels can occur between two
participants solo duels or two teams of
two Duo duels
oh my gosh James dude expecto
you gotta be my dueling buddy
you just saw it on your in-game mail
okay
I need to check that
dual tears
your dual tier is determined by your
performance in duels winning a dual
grants dual score accumulating which can
unlock higher tiers all right
and then I'll see details to ensure the
fairness of each duel the maximum card
level has been set oh that's cool
so we're not gonna be getting thrown
into ridiculously high level players
right away
upon reaching Grand Master tier and a
certain dual score Milestone
accomplished duelist will be invited to
our exciting Global duel
as its name suggests Global duel allows
its participants to compete against
players worldwide for a place on the
world leaderboard
after qualifying for the global duel
which is in Wizards will unlock a new
Echo leaderboard and its responding
titles okay we don't know what all this
means yet because we're not
we're not that high level of a player
yet
your place on the echo leaderboard is
determined by Echo points which will
increase or decrease with each Global
dual match based on the outcome I have
heard that if you really want to get
high level that is unfortunately where
the Pay to Win kind of comes into it
that you have to have a lot of the
higher level cards
and one of the ways you get them is by
spending unfortunately
all right uh check out the shop page
shop on Lots
all right speaking of micro transactions
here we go
this is our first look at the shop basic
study guaranteed card in 0 out of 30
draws open card packs with keys obtained
from the dueling Club wait do I want to
do like I think I have to do that right
open to get two cards so we have a 1.89
chance
of getting an epic
33 chance rare 66 chance on a common
[Applause]
here we go
Epic
no way
let's go dude bombastic bomb box
you guys are gonna be like yeah
everybody gets an epic the first time
oh man that's funny
[Music]
do the two available duels today oh yeah
Ryan let me know how to do that and I'll
I'll go do that here
bombastic bomb box summons a bombastic
bomb box that creates bombs everyone's
I knew it man I knew like the first one
they're gonna give you an epic
that's too funny the bombs will also
directly go for opponents when they are
in range units with bombs have increased
movement speed
when a bomb carrying Ally unit attacks
the bomb will fly towards the first
enemy struck and detonate dealing AOE
damage if an ally unit with a bomb is
defeated the bomb will explode on the
spot deals 50 more damage if the
explosion Only Hits one target
[Music]
okay
can upgrade to level two I don't know
what that means
okay that's the one we already have and
it's a common it's level one
oh maybe I have to hit continue right
here
wait what does this do
spin coins to make the spell stronger
okay gotcha
so do I hit
I don't have 30 of these things yet
okay no
all right I guess I don't have to do
this I'm gonna hit back
all right Advanced study
[Music]
oh we own zero of those I see now okay
the one was throwing me off yo Elwyn
[Music]
and yeah uh Jake you should already
accepted your your other one but you
should still be able to send a request
level up spell in the deck page oh my
gosh dude we got we got so much to learn
about this game
so much to learn
all right here's what I'm gonna do oh
wait free items
protego totalum common card
all right that was free though that was
free
so if we want to add that to our deck
we'll have to go in and
customize it
all right what are Loyalty Rewards by
getting loyalty points
looks like I don't have any of these yet
oh man there's so much to see so much to
do
okay here's what I want to figure out
first
I want to figure out how I
let's see who was it moonlace said I saw
it in my in-game mail
that is what I want to do first
[Applause]
okay and this is how we would swap out
things
the monster book I feel like is pretty
good
[Music]
I'll do what would I want to swap it out
with cast a shield at a Target location
to take damage for Ally units within its
radius
I feel like that'd be good to kind of
start a fight with that
but oh here's the other strategy though
you're gonna need a balance of like
lower level cards and higher level cards
right
you don't want everything just high this
is level six though I definitely need to
put that in there
okay back row and damage of three
front row a damage of three
front row damage of four
or front row rating of four and then a
damage of three I think front row is
like a defense kind of stat
all right so let's put
this one in for sure
and it's telling me we can level it up
jw345
accepted oh no where'd it go why does it
take me out like that
why does it take me out
what I just changed this let's see what
did I do I took the spiders out
and I put you in
[Music]
flatus I feel like is really strong I
don't want to get rid of that one
but I could see this Shield thing being
kind of useful and it has like a a four
bonus
that does damage does this one do any
damage
no so this is just purely like Shield
right here
purely a shield I'm gonna keep that one
disabled for now but I want to figure
out how to like oh here it is I could
use 100 gold to upgrade the Spider card
I'm not gonna do that yet though I'm
Gonna Save that
all right now how do I save this
just back up there we go
okay
you can't wait for me to try dancing oh
boy
all right where is our in-game mail
we can duel again I think it wants us to
duel again
oh looking for players no no no no no no
no
now we're battling Lottie
I was like don't actually I'm not ready
to fight real people yet
definitely not ready to fight real
people
okay here's what I want to do first
honestly I'm a little bit nervous but I
think it's
I don't have my trolley yet
okay I'm Gonna Save that one
I don't know why I just leaped forward
like that
troll in the dungeon
I'll do that incendio was really hurting
us
there we go
yeah let's get out of there
you almost got her
almost got her
opponent defeated
yeah
thankfully that wasn't a real person
is that the one you were talking about
doing Ryan to make sure that I did to uh
the two available duels to pick up the
extra cards let's see because that was
one let's see if we got any cards for
that
total score nice okay and so then how do
I do the next one do I just hit match
again
or is there anything else I need like I
don't know how I actually got that
person the well it wasn't a real person
but
okay we just hit match again perfect
see this one's oh and it's Lottie again
all right
it didn't give me any cards though did
it maybe you have to complete both of
them first
it's gonna be so much fun I just know
you'll love it too
let's get out of that
oh dude she just took out
those little bombs
so quickly
[Music]
there we go
a better silver oh I got a gold P okay
nice
oh it it played as a niffler too
that's so funny
oh she's doing some kind of healing
healing there
no way
oh it launched the troll too when she
did esposo right there
oh vintus was too I think I was too far
away right there
hey we did the same spell
well we almost got her almost got her
there we go
get a better silver key now perfect
oh there we go okay so we got a hundred
gold five gems one golden key a
delightful drop
by participating in dueling Club daily
you have a chance to trigger delightful
drops and get silver keys or golden keys
at random Max three times every day okay
so you need to make sure we do that
tap to continue
all right so that's it right what
happens if we do it again then do we
start playing real players
bash a box who's that is that one of you
in here
I'm assuming so I'll accept it okay
let's see social
oh oh dude wait here's where you can
chat with any of you
that's so cool
[Music]
yo James still hasn't oh here we go here
we go here we go
here's how I claim the rewards
all right your WB Games thank you for
linking you can now log into your game
account on multiple devices and restore
your account if you need to reinstall
your game or update your device
that is awesome
that is awesome shout out to WB for that
one
shout out
for that one
all right
you can now log into your game account
all right but wait how do I oh I hit
claim right here claim yes
rewards obtained
oh wait where's all the pre-register
thing wait claim all
was that all the stuff that you get for
the uh the pre-registration as well
[Music]
I don't think so yeah I didn't get all
the
well now we got two of those Advanced
study ones right there
Okay so
legendary
interesting
it's a different set I thought so
moonlace
so where do I where do I do that
or why were mine not mine weren't in
there
I'm worried why weren't they in there
oh my gosh fiend fire for 20 000 gold
just trying to get an idea of what
everything costs in here
uh I think you should be able to still
link your your WB yeah
[Music]
I went out now Luna okay
go to settings all right let me go to
settings here are you talking about are
you talking about how to link it up
okay now we're now we're back out head
to the charms classroom we're going back
to charms again
Fisher Fray
oh for the linking okay that's what I
thought
oh my gosh I could see you chatting Jake
I saw your name down there
that's too cool
talk to The Fray twins okay let's take a
closer look yep
talk to them you two look like you're up
to no good what's in the box
in the Box
what is in the Box
what box I don't see no rocks
clearly I mean the box right there
what this is a box it's a collection of
explosive accessories dangerous Delights
dangerous Delights
oh filter he's still here teaching all
these years later it's you and your
notebooks want attention
scram
better idea why don't you explain the
filter what you're doing with fees
later loser
unused Keys available okay it's telling
me I need to use those keys but I want
to save them I don't want to use them
yet
okay so I hit charms bottom right that's
what took me to this page this is where
you can work on in building your deck
okay perfect
just trying to get familiar with where
everything is located then we have our
knapsack
okay that's where you can see our info
this
oh then you could like post and say hey
guys join me here that's cool
[Music]
that's where we look at requests again
all right so how do we get there we got
there by going to the knapsack and then
info New Look mirror okay that's where
you change up what you're wearing for
the day
and I guess you could just change this
stuff at any time
that's kind of cool
so we don't have any of this stuff yet
some of these we don't
[Music]
redeem maybe we have to redeem something
what is this download button
additional sets oh I was like additional
assets I mean yeah don't we want to
download everything
[Music]
just go ahead and download all
wait did that just trigger
I think these are the rewards
that still wasn't all of them though
that was not all of them
yeah Cloud Roth I I am it took us a
while to get it up and running but
I'm still very early
still kind of figuring out the battling
and everything
and there's so much in terms of
navigating the menus that's what we're
just sort of trying to navigate right
now and I'm trying to make sure that I
got all of the
so you got some rewards for
pre-registering remember how they had
the little progress bar on all that
and I mean I'm pretty sure I did
everything
and so when I just hit download all that
actually
a bunch of things started popping
through right then
okay
oh dude I didn't even know that you
could you could go in here and change
the okay so we're on the best setting
right now
redeem
I wonder if this is where we're supposed
to put it in like if we need a code or
something
[Music]
battle information simple classic or
custom
oh so if you put it on classic it gives
you their name
oh and you can change it PVE versus PVP
[Music]
tap ground to use movement cards oh yo
dorm mates Dylan yes
let's go I sincerely invite you to be my
roommate the dormitory is cool
Dylan I'm glad you're keeping things
nice and tidy in there
appreciate you doing that
glad you're keeping it nice and tidy
oh my gosh there's so many settings that
we're gonna have to
tweak
inspect the strange box all right let's
inspect it
what a pair of kits bilches in the
prefix bathroom cleaning up after peeves
again
yeah I'll let you know in about a week
Cloud Roth see how much I I keep
enjoying it like the only thing right
now I wish I I wish I had a controller
or I could use my mouse and keyboard but
the emulators weren't working very well
so I'm having to like mirror this
through my iPhone and so I'm having to
play directly on my phone I'd be having
a lot more fun if I was playing on my
keyboard or if it had controller support
which I haven't tested if it has control
or support yet or not I doubt it though
because there's there's so much of it
that requires you actually like dragging
things like when you're playing with the
the cards and the battles
all right return to the charms classroom
okay that's the dueling Club there
wait where are we going
where is the charms classroom
they actually expect me to remember they
know they're dealing with here
I have terrible sense of Direction
no way they're gonna make us find it
again on our own right okay we got the
map in the top left oh what you guys you
guys can't see the mini map
there's really not actually
there's not a great spot for me to put
the webcam
I'm playing directly on my iPhone Jake
uh Jay it is out now in uh all
territories worldwide
oh what do we have here
yo rewards obtained let's go
[Music]
oh I can just tap on it and it'll return
me
what are they doing here oh my gosh
that's so awesome let's go
deal with the frey twins
what do you mean deal with them
battle oh we gotta battle them
no way you told us filter was coming but
he was nowhere near was he
that means you tricked us and we don't
like to be tricked do we brother
these guys are so funny man
we do not
oh they're gonna take me two on one oh
yikes
oh wait
fantastic bomb
can increase the movement speed of
summon creatures and cause their attacks
to deal AOE damage all right
[Music]
look the bombs can follow all sorts of
nearby creatures including spiders oh
that's cool
spiders
whoa look at that now try to use the
bombastic bombs with other summonables
to beat the phrase
okay so we had to do the bombs first
all right so bombs bombs out first let's
put the mic over here
and then I mean the troll
does the troll does it do anything extra
with the troll
s
of course now Luna's wanting back in the
room
and do an inflatus right there okay so
that one missed didn't even matter
though didn't even matter
Fury I think
bombtastic bomb boxes are fun
they are fun
I should probably get rid of these I
wouldn't want filter to think they're
mine
foreign
[Music]
twins I think we dealt with them right
there
head to the castle corridor
oh my gosh look at Fields man
a box of boomtastic bubble blasts it's
just a misunderstanding these aren't
mine
I've had that one before ravanaugh dude
look at his character model man so good
run away or leave wait what isn't that
the same thing
is that the same thing
oh man
okay talk to Daniel Daniel's right there
isn't he
I'm enjoying it so far yeah and I think
it's it's fun
I'm still very early but I just wish I
could figure out how to get my rewards
it doesn't look like they've came
through yet
let's just say I've run into some rather
explosive troubles with the caretaker
filch yeah he's got it in for me too
he's convinced I was pilfering potions
ingredients from the store room I mean
right Lauren Skywalker is leave or run
away
hmm
delightful
light we'll be waving it
a great wizard keeps their calm
even in the base dire of circumstances
oh if you've got any suggestions I'm
listening
very well allow me to tell you about a
duel oh no is this one of the Echoes
where you get to relive a memory I
didn't witness it myself of course but I
have friends hung in the ministry who
say it was most epic
portrait story
I need him why would I need a moment
I wouldn't have started talking to you
oh my gosh let's go yes
dude
this moment is so epic
do we get to actually play this oh we do
drag the orb of water to Voldemort's
location
they actually have the orb of water
spell
oh my gosh
the orb of water moves when you do
okay
oh dude that's cool
is that the only spell we have though
oh I probably need to get rid of that
don't I
oh no it didn't do anything he just
tried to cast a okay on us
I don't like that
no double door move
Dumbledore you gotta get out of the way
he's casting AK on us left and right
all of Walter
there we go there we go there we go
Voldemort come down
oh my gosh Voldemort
he's just casting it over and over
he is beating us right now though
can I actually I I thought I had it
right on this guy
there we go okay I guess I just missed
before
dude's got Dementors
pure totem locomotor someone's
practically indestructible stone statues
yeah we definitely need some help
there we go Dumbledore show your
Transfiguration skills
baby Anthony and opal eye summons a baby
dragon that breathes fire
yeah
yeah let's do it
thunderstorm causes a Thunderbird okay
now we're seeing the powerful spells we
got the we got the big time Wizards in
Action here thunderstorm causes a
Thunderbird to strike a random opponent
with lightning okay
it's a random Target
oh so it just yeah we don't know who
it's gonna hit
that is amazing
I cannot believe Voldemort just
repeatedly
it's Walter
all of water
dude Voldemort bringing out the
werewolves now
oh yeah we need we need our
let's put these guys right here
I mean it's AK and insta kill
I think we were about to find out
I like these statues man
practically indestructible they said
come on we need that to hit Voldemort
darn it
what's going on on screen right now
all right we're ahead of him now we're
ahead
dude it's kind of crazy this is a mobile
game
is a mobile game
I don't know man maybe mobile games have
improved a lot I don't I don't play a
lot of mobile games but
this is crazy impressive I feel like
we got the epic music going too
trial complete we got him
let's go
GG's Dumbledore
well played Dumbledore well played
exactly Owen way more fun but my
personal favorite is potions
that was cool man
sport where you get to ride a broomstick
well we're really are we like we know
nothing about the Wizards everyone
very little I'm interested
thank you Jared appreciate it
all you just did that for me what say
what Dylan
oh my goodness moonless 2 A.M
all good hey appreciate you stopping by
have a good night
a good sleep hope you get some rest all
right head to the grade Hall
I can just tap on the
task complete
unlock rewards in the shop
a golden key can unlock more Rewards
okay so I think this is the one that we
they probably we probably have to do
this one
maybe we don't but we had three I should
still probably go ahead and get one
what's gonna be
come on give us a legendary
oh is it that one that Dumbledore was
using
a sounds good Lauren enjoy your lunch
oh the baby dragon one
the baby antipodyian opal eye
yes
someone's a baby antibody and opalai
okay we read that back row and then
damage of four
like I wanna
yeah
oh Anna gave us that one too
someone's both Fisher Fray and Colby
Frey to Aid you
know why we got so many right there
[Music]
unlimited chances to redraw this time
I feel like we should take advantage of
that but I have no idea what's good and
what's not
Draco is Draco still here
oh man I need somebody who's been
playing this game a lot
should I redraw because I I guess you
get
you can you get unlimited chances right
here
I mean I definitely liked that Dragon
one was pretty good
but I don't know like what are all the
other options out there
is this one right here ackermancial is
nest
I'm pretty sure this is a one-time thing
that you get to redraw
the game is way more fun while watching
your stream alongside hey hello world
appreciate you saying that thank you so
much for the kind words
very very kind of you to say
hit redraw okay all right I was like is
Draco here I need to know what's good
okay when using a golden key for the
first time you have the option to redraw
as many times as you want each redraw
gives you an equal chance of getting one
of the five legendary cards above okay
keep in mind that if you redraw it
you'll lose the cards you just received
yeah yeah we're good with that
you will receive all five hop options
yes okay so which one am I going after
Draco which one do you think is the best
we've got the lightning we've got the
baby antibody and opalite we've got the
water we've got what looks like Draco
Malfoy and we've got those statues
the statues were pretty good in that
battle but I don't know I have no idea
what Malfoy does
your phone gets really hot
mine does feel a little warm
I've got a case on there but it's it's
not like crazy warm
the best one is the lightning all right
see Draco knows you guys we're gonna
keep redrawing until we get that
lightning one
all right boom
and this is just a one-time thing
okay we want to skip this because we've
already seen it oh this scene cannot be
skipped what
why can it not be skipped
did we actually get the same thing
oh we did we got the same one
wait we got the same one there too
oh no okay wait
oh and we got we didn't get as many
cards that time
excuse me oh we got two of that one over
here on the left the exploso all right
let's redraw
you just got the lightning there you go
hello world there you go
wait wait is this the lightning
no
I did like this one in that battle but
I'm gonna trust Draco Draco knows what
he's talking about
then you get fantas again okay so it
looks like you get vintus in the frey
twins oh
we got the Whomping Willow too though
that's funny
all right redraw
we're redrawing again we want the
lightning
in the end it all depends on the echo
okay but lightning is kind of like the
best overall I'm nice
oh this is orb of water isn't it oh both
Walter
all right well we've gotten three of
them so far
got a is that a blasted it's screwed no
no all the animations and stuff on these
cards man it's just so good
new store how's it going welcome in
come on come on Lightning give it to us
this is it this is it this is it
that's the Thunderbird
get that nice little animation with uh
was that Newt that looked like newt's
Commander right there
orb is great for a few things like team
exploring
what do you what do you mean by EX Team
okay someone's a thunderstorm to call
upon
oh someone's a Thunderbird to call upon
a thunderstorm 15 bolts of lightning
each bolt will hit a random opponent and
apply a heel reduction effect okay
that's cool
after defeating five opponent units the
remaining lightning bolts will strike
all opponent units
and then we got the Ventus again we also
got the frey twins
and then we got Daniel page someone's
Daniel who restores Health to all nearby
Ally units upon entering the battlefield
he then continues to use heal Ally units
at the cost of his health oh a little
like self-sacrifice there
and then we got esposo there all right
so this I'm gonna take this one with our
lightning here confirm
all right there we go
Draco do you while you're still here do
you know how I get all of the uh like
pre
not pre-order but all the rewards that
we that we unlocked as a community do
you know how I get those because I don't
think I did yet I don't think it gave
them to me
a monthly card
oh okay we get to check our cards again
when you start or join a team you can do
some group type events like classrooms
and Team Force explore ah okay the
better you all do the better rewards
gotcha okay
so that's where orb of water can come in
handy choose your favorite cards
wait what is I only have two options
wait what was that
I don't understand what's going on here
why okay that that's magic and then we
have companions so I guess I only have
two companions right now
these two
yeah so they're like in a different
category
all right we definitely want to get the
lightning in there
I'm gonna take this one out for now
wait did it not work did it not take it
out oh
gotta put it over there
oh once you finish part of a story okay
perfect dude I was so worried about that
thank you for answering that the part of
the story where you catch a niffler nice
I was like why is it not giving me all
that stuff
enrollment pack team up with The Lovable
half giant who embodies the spirit of
Hogwarts amazing deal wait do I have to
buy this
enrollment pack
I don't think we have these do we have
300 of this
I don't know
a duel Dylan I'm not ready to duel
people yet
I can't be dueling
I can't be dueling real people yet
I gotta get some practice in
should I do this
I don't even know if I have these
oh I don't I don't have it okay it's
five bucks all right
I gotta I'm like trying to learn what
are the micro transactions and what
what or not okay talk to Robin about
broomstick flying let's go man
so right now we can just do it I keep
looking at my phone I need to look up
here it looks so good like I am I can't
believe
how good it looks with this setup that
we got going on right now guys if you're
just tuning in if you haven't been here
from the beginning uh the setup that
we've got going right now is I have I am
mirroring this from my iPhone
you can see there I mean look at this
let's see if we can uh
look at that dude is that not crazy I am
mirroring it from my iPhone
to my MacBook Air
and then capturing that to my PC with a
capture card
so as a result I can see it on this big
screen in front of me and it looks so
good like I figured with all that
scaling and stuff that was going on that
there would be some uh like a
significant downgrade or something but
no it looks pretty good
oh we can't talk to McGonagall
[Music]
can we not talk to you McGonagall can we
sit
can we sit down here
dude these people are just going crazy
though with the food look at this
oh now now that I want to come watch
you're going to stop you're you're like
a little self-conscious okay it's all
right I get it oh look there they go
though as we walk away now they're
eating again
all right let's talk to Robin about
broomstick flying
where is she
Robin
oh wait hold on Cassandra had something
to say he's still upset about that duel
earlier Cassandra
what are you wearing is that your
mother's old robe go to Madame malkin's
robes and get some new clothes I just
can't stand your old-fashioned look
I'll do we about to tell her off
Sandra you know what
you know what mind your own business
all right here's Robin
Daniela
welcome in dude appreciate you stopping
by welcome to your first ever stream
thank you for supporting yeah this is a
brand new uh free to play mobile game
called Harry Potter magic awakened
hey buddy I think she wants out to see
you guys you can let her out
y'all have fun
cool
actually yeah I don't know much about
flying on broomsticks at all yeah
maybe she got one out
I don't know much about flying a
broomsticks at all yeah so it's uh it's
it's available for free anywhere in the
world on IOS and Android
and uh there is going to be a PC client
as well there's also uh Android
emulators that you can use which I've
heard they're not running well today
um I'm a BlueStacks affiliate and
BlueStacks was working great for us at
the beginning
but then it just like it just quit and a
lot a lot of people were apparently
having trouble with with a lot of
different emulators but if you guys did
want to support it is a free to download
that if you want to try it out to play
it on your PC
uh exclamation point blue Stacks in the
chat or you can look in the video
description it'll get it for you I don't
know if they're working yet or not but I
assume they will be at some point it's
just probably with it being launch day
it's probably a little crazy and
everything for the first day
so yeah right now we're playing on a
a very interesting setup with the the
screen mirroring from our iPhone
off we go on our little Adventure
off we go on a little Adventure
oh man what's the flying gonna be like
in this
yeah no problem Daniel I mean it's free
to play might as well try it out I'm
normally not a big mobile game player
but if you're a Wizarding World fan at
all I mean so far I'm I am super
impressed
I mean like
I'm enjoying this way more than I
thought I would try flying outside the
Great Hall yo Dylan oh my gosh
how'd you find me dude there's Dylan you
guys
yo
yo it's your boy Dylan
see this is why I'm so excited for these
types of games man I mean we've been
saying a Harry Potter MMO would do
incredibly well
I meant like a you know a console PC
game
oh Dylan you just showing off now he's
just showing off look at this
he's got like some little eat what is
this like a little emote thing going
that is too cool
all right so I think we have to talk to
Robin about flying fast
now climb on and when you're ready push
off the ground
ride okay
right yo jzt
[Music]
oh come on all right I accepted it
swipe to adjust the camera all right
okay now how do we follow
drag to move release to stop
oh that actually feels
actually feels really nice
okay I'm not in control right now
look to the Horizon if you're ever
feeling scared
am I in control yet
no we're still not in control
oh Jenny you were there too no way oh
this is crazy you guys
how many people can you get together
with and go through the Forbidden Forest
to do the Forbidden Forest runs
because that I think is gonna be
a lot of fun to hop in with you guys
do you want to dance is it time to learn
that
I'm not controlling any of this you guys
I wasn't controlling any of that
50. you could have 50 people in the
forest
oh my gosh that's amazing my only other
one was Kevin that's amazing
Lauren uh all you missed was uh we just
did our first flying and we saw Dylan
walking around
thanks Robin you're a great teacher
better wanna go again
uh no thanks I'm good I want to see it
was fun but I want to see the other
things I don't know why I wasn't
controlling I don't know if that was on
purpose or what but I wasn't in control
of that I wish I
wait sign in
sign in is not available yet complete
yearbook stories and enrollment deal
progress through yearbook stories to
claim up to 30 Ruby keys
and then you have enrollment deals
get 10 pulls for only nine keys
oh it lets you try out the card
dude I'm like I'm slightly overwhelmed
at all this I'm not gonna lie
now how do I get back to that other
thing
open your knapsack all right
camera
oh dude that's cool
[Music]
oh yeah yeah let's fly over here
dude this is basically like a photo mode
okay I want to turn it
oh my phone is getting really hot now
Anna where I've been playing for a while
maybe
like I want you to be able to see me in
the photo too
oh kind of like right there
right there right there right there
all right now let's see that says new
right there a filter
afternoon in the library oh this is so
cool
all right I'm just gonna go with the the
regular one
and then what are these
all my memories first time at the
dueling Club
and then our photos will show here
all right so how do I get rid of all the
menu
hide UI there we go
wait I said hide UI
what is portrait mode oh it kind of
blurs out the background
oh that's perfect it takes it
automatically removes it
okay I want to download this
uh yes confirm
allow access
and then you could just tweet it out too
[Music]
that's really cool I like that
all right so now head to herbology and
then also aguamenti
remember remember to search for pots and
chests you get gems and gold yeah I did
find a little uh random pot earlier
that I made sure to grab can you also
get them when you're flying around like
this too
yeah see now I'm fully in control
oh we got the Whomping wheel over here
all right
the wamping Willows got me
the one pin Willow
got Hagrid's Hut over here and then all
you guys are just like here in the world
I'm sorry I know many games have done
stuff I know mini games have done this
before
but I just can't get over the idea that
I'm like flying around and seeing you
guys in the world
that is so cool we got some people
playing quidditch over here oh question
mark
wait what have I done
what have I done
oh my goodness
this is actually really difficult
[Music]
this is actually really really difficult
come on
oh we're on a timer
come on no
goodness dude
uh is it obvious that I don't play
mobile games very much there we go we
got it
I don't even know what we got for that
but that was cool
and then we got people like actually
playing quidditch over here or is it
just like a
I don't think these are real people I
think this is just a practice going on
see if it if it does the same thing
oh that turn right there
oh man
I don't know why I flew all the way back
I just don't want to break my momentum
turn
the last one go
there we go
all right I don't want to do that again
I don't know if it's giving me anything
or not
like what happens if I hit this little
chat box down here
hello people
of the
internet
feature locked
how's that locked
I don't know why it's locked maybe I
haven't progressed far enough or
something
or maybe it's because I did hide my
personal information oh I didn't mean to
do that
I did not mean to activate it again
[Music]
okay dude this is
I need a controller I need a controller
at the very least I need a mouse and
keyboard
you need to progress further okay gotcha
I know Lord I love the little uh the
music as you go
uh house what's up welcome in I am
indeed in uh
in Opel eye
[Music]
need to progress further okay perfect
some things you can't open gotcha all
right let's go ahead and head to uh
what do I do to get augmenti here maybe
that's what I do in herbology
we actually just have to fly over there
huh
there's no like fast travel or anything
from here I guess
not that I'm complaining about the
flying because Oh wrong way
right here
phone's gonna die soon I know it but I
have backup hey it's Neville
new okay and then we also have the
camera right there
that's so cool
that is so cool
all right so we got inspect and then
talk to Neville let's inspect first
oh right there there we go Draco that's
what Draco was talking about you gotta
be on the lookout for little things that
you can
interact with around the world
okay and then we would exit into the
castle right there
[Music]
all right Neville what's up hello I'm
glad you're here I could use your help
watering a few Professor Longbottom
it's so good to see you Neville
um sure do you have a watering can
no need just use the aguamenti charm
aquamenti
Ally I know it's a bit Advanced but
Professor Flitwick mentioned he was
going to introduce it earlier this year
here's your chance to practice
all right I'll give it a go
cast aguaminty on the sapling
right here
oh dude look
the bow truffles
cast augmenti on this wait did I not do
it right did I mess up Neville treated
you as a peace offering before he
decides to gouge out your eyes
[Music]
yes treat
quickly
quickly he needs a treat there's some
bow truck will feed me those old flower
pots that Hagrid dropped off earlier
careful though I found a few gnomes
hiding in the pots I got most of them
but there might be a few left
foreign
be careful okay
no way they got gnomes in this game too
all right inspect the pots I think we're
supposed to go
this way right here
let's see uh here's the feed
and also there he is
oh they look creepy they look more
creepy than the remember the ones in the
Chamber of Secrets video game
oh we gotta battle the Gnomes no way
all right gnomes let's go
let's go gnomes
defeat the Gnomes in the greenhouse
oh we only have one try using augmenti
on the Gnomes
uh let's hit these two right here
oh wow it does really fast takes them
down quickly all right which way do you
want me to move you can move while
casting
oh you want me to go that way okay
oh and it keeps going
clutch clutch more gnomes have appeared
and let's get an inflatus on these two
right here
what do these guys do
I haven't used them yet
now you're in
the alpha gnome has appeared defeated
oh we're about to get our our Lightning
Spell
yes
so this is our legendary
implementing
so you have to really like make sure
you're lining it up
the fact that you can move around with
augmenti
hey static thank you so much for the
follow
oh it popped up behind my
house yes I'll accept your friend
request there
interact with the bow truffle at the
herbology classroom
right here is the bow struggle
I'm sorry about the wall test static
appreciate you subscribing to the
channel by the way
lets out a sound of satisfaction that
was quite a big trait I think you made a
friend for life
but do try to be more careful you never
know what might be lurking under the
next League
interact with the bow trickle yes
complete
oh it's dance club time you guys
you all were saying you couldn't wait
for me to get to that part
we're almost there
all right so yeah augmenti I feel like
it was pretty strong right there
level three all right talk to
headmistress McGonagall
[Music]
there was an M riddle right there
got Tom riddles descendant no way
is it already snowing outside
I think it might just be the
some something something magical going
on
[Music]
the crazy one says this is gonna be good
uh oh
why hello retro I'm pleased to see
you've joined us
[Music]
I've been wanting to practice my dancing
skills for a while now oh
McGonagall how'd you know
how'd you know
this is exactly what we've wanted to do
previous experience oh yeah we do
I used to watch my parents watch in the
living room my mom tried to teach me a
few steps but
you worry you may not have All the Right
Moves wait why does she not have voice
acting here that's weird
nothing to be nervous about I created
this club to help everyone with a
passion for dancing find their feet so
to speak I was so inspired by the impact
that the Triwizard Yule Ball had on the
school's morale that I knew I had to
make dancing a regular event so you
enjoy dancing as well Professor enjoy it
why did child I may not look it but I
was quite a sprightly last in my day
I loved Waltzing almost as much as I
enjoyed turning mice into teacups wow
huh I look forward to learning more
during the week the club practices their
dances okay and on the weekend we offer
more formal performances in front of
your classmates
gosh I gotta perform in front of you
guys
what
that sounds intimidating nah we'll be
good we'll be good
love this game
yes
could you imagine
well I actually feel like this would be
great on the switch would it not oh man
this would be great on the switch
I'll go see what I can do thanks
professor I mean because the switch has
a touch screen talk to Robin and Kevin
oh my goodness so many of you guys are
here or all you guys are gonna be
watching
all you guys gonna be watching me dance
for the first time wait why can we not
trying to get over here to them okay
there's Robin
wait I just tapped there we go
you're in the Forbidden Force right now
Jenny
I wouldn't need to be here if Robin
hadn't forced me to come
don't listen to him he's having a blast
[Music]
I don't know why the voice acting
doesn't happen here in this part
ah
[Music]
I'm not certain or I'm nervous to ask
I mean I guess I'm not certain ah
why don't you try Dan
really Cassandra
they're your friends
they're not my friends dude
oh come on Robin let's dance with me
instead of Kevin here
invite Daniel invite Cassandra
Cassandra's gonna say no man
oh wait you have to actually walk over
to her
right in front of McGonagall too here we
go
okay thank you
because I'm only going to say this once
while dancing simply hit the buttons to
the Beat of the Music use headphones for
the best experience all right we got it
[Music]
tap the button once try to aim for
exactly when the circle's overlap
oh my gosh this is like
this is like one of my favorite
speaking of the DS one of my favorite DS
games ever
Elite beat agents
oh my goodness okay tap the button once
try to aim for exactly when the circle's
overlap okay so when that Outer Circle
gets right over that outer edge
the timing is perfect
all right tap on the correct buttons in
succession will increase your combo
count and overall score you've got this
okay try to do a combo all right
[Music]
did a lot better than I expected
come on Cassandra give us a little bit
of credit here
now it's gonna get hard though right
now it's gonna get hard
it's time to practice what you learned
okay here we go
oh here's our first song cloudtop steps
I'm nervous
here we go here we go
[Music]
the music feels off with the tapping
oh excellent darn it
my first excellent
okay
foreign
[Music]
chat I'm sorry
we're locked in dude we gotta impress
Cassandra here
we gotta impressed Cassandra
[Applause]
we had dude
oh my gosh we only had one that we
missed we we didn't miss any one
excellent
oh man accuracy 100 percent
so close oh we got the double s we got
the double s let's go
what were you guys thinking it was gonna
be terrible come on come on go ahead
admit it admit it you guys thought it
was gonna be terrible didn't you
you guys didn't know about my background
with the elite beat agents
on the Nintendo DS
you just had no idea
hey what's up extra Whitey welcome in no
we're not we we do have a we do have an
emulator installed on our computer
BlueStacks is what we're using there's
an affiliate link it's free you can
download it
um there's an affiliate link to download
it and try it in the description
however a lot of the emulators I don't
know if it's launch day or what they
were having some trouble today so we
started on the emulator and then it it
failed so now we are actually playing on
our iPhone and just uh mirroring it to
my MacBook and then capturing it with a
capture card so yeah the the official PC
client did not release unfortunately in
the US yet they don't have a an ETA on
that yet
anyone willing to befriend a newbie to
this type of gameplay I have a lot to
learn you mean that right there or just
the overall game I mean because so far
we've done there's like a little bit of
exploration then we've done like the
card combat
and what else we had a little bit of
flying which was I'm not the one to give
you advice on that flying I was all over
the place then you had this type of
gameplay which was really cool I I
actually like this a lot
the dancing I love Rhythm games like
that there's a there was an old iPhone
game too that was on the uh
oh I can't remember the name of it but
it was like it was just like that like
tapping the the circles
I don't know if it's where I'm streaming
or what but the music was definitely
what I was hearing was off
with what I was seeing so it was I'm
honestly surprised I did that well
because
yeah it did not feel like I was
it did not sound like I was uh on time
with those
oh look at this the nice little blue and
white tie I love it
task complete fireworks can now be
viewed in your knapsack let's go that's
how Dylan got the fireworks you guys
select the fireworks to unleash
okay let's do uh let's do a green
oh and then you hit like the check mark
hey there we go
got the green and the red going main
story The Night Ivy went missing wait is
this all our first day
this was all from our first day no way
that's crazy
Christian gamer yeah I think what it
what is uh anybody who's played the
played the game what exactly is is the
group
and how many people can be in it is it
because we definitely should set one up
or we could also see I don't know James
is probably already going to be filled
up I bet his will be filled up
if any of you guys are in James's stream
by the way tell him to accept my friend
requests
tell him I said or just don't tell him
to accept tell him I sent him one and I
think he'll he'll see it
actually let me see how do we even get
back to there let's see I'm still trying
to figure out all the controls okay it
wasn't charms
it was um
oh where do we go to get there
why do members get it's uh unfortunately
it's not like twitch where if you're
subscribed you don't see ads to not see
ads on YouTube you have to be um
you have to have YouTube premium but
that's like a separate thing next time
though you guys shouldn't see them
during the live stream I didn't know
they were going to be so uh
so invasive I think YouTube it's not an
option I'd seen before so I just clicked
it because like I mean I want my my
videos to have monetization on them
but um it enabled them I guess it just
keeps spamming them because a lot of
people keep commenting on it
but I want to make sure they're on there
for the VOD so I'm gonna have to read
I'm gonna have to read into that
all your first experience playing on a
phone gotcha
the teams are limited to 50 okay
so we're gonna have to put together a
team you guys
I'm gonna have to figure out a way to uh
because I would definitely I think we'll
easily be able to get 50. so I'm gonna
have to figure out the criteria who gets
who gets in
okay why is this little thing showing up
here
great deal
bundles
I'm not gonna I don't wanna do any of
this right now
I just wondered why that little card was
showing up in the top right
events oh I forgot about this complete
yearbook stories
oh that's what we're about to do
actually
that is what we're about to do head to
the dormitory yeah we're ready for the
main story section right here
[Music]
Jake with the tin
appreciate it dude you better fight me
I don't even know how any of it works
dude don't know how any of it works
we're gonna have to figure all that out
in due time
in due time we were figure all of that
out social yeah that's gotta be it there
you go thank you Lauren good eye there
good eye
okay yeah so there's all of you that
have added so far and then let's see
does it have my
official accounts
wait what is an official account
is that like uh an employee or something
[Music]
and then I'm pretty sure I already sent
James an invite
oh wait what was this
oh these are are these the teams
join the Phoenix Seekers
oh yeah that's a team
a world Channel
I don't want to mess mess with any of
this
until I know what I'm doing
find a social club
beat your locked okay so I haven't
progressed the story far enough I don't
even need to worry about this yet
to ask for someone you meet later okay
gotcha
main story time let's go
so I spent but somehow I can't fall
asleep why does it look so weird it's
like something's blocking my view I
heard that Ivy is still missing it where
could she be
I can't wait anymore
the more people looking for her the more
hopes she'll have her being found
is Dylan in here
let's go
wait who else are our dorm mates
oh and you named it raconteur Dylan you
the man dude you the man
or is it still just oh I think we got a
third we probably have a third
we need one more to join our
I want to be able to see like who else
is in here
oh you got you've got like the little
portrait right there
and so then there's there's one spot
there that is so cool man
okay wait it says view right there let
me hit View
Robo Panda and Dylan okay it's Robo
Panda there we go
okay let me before I hit look for Ivy
Moon Lily with the friend request there
we go I'm going to get my battery pack
for my phone because I don't want it to
die you can see there in the bottom left
it's kind of getting low
I do not want it to die
[Music]
foreign
oh no seven six we got it
just in time
Mia what's up Mia we are um
opal eye is what we're on
opal eye
all right so here we got the battery
pack
oh no I missed James seriously
[Music]
all right so now we're charging and
playing okay let's check see if we got
one from James
where do I go to seed my invites
of course I was walking away
foreign
you just had to restart your entire game
no Roger
okay mine was just opal eye
automatically and that's what James said
to join so
where do I see requests you guys why
would they not
it's not in my inbox
[Music]
it's got to be somewhere right
oh wait add friend
there we go
foreign
yo look it's expect to go he says he's a
big fan of the channel
I think we should accept him what do you
guys think
William pear hi I'm William pair
I think you're from the stream William
I'm gonna accept you too so accept
everybody there we go
dude this is actually so cool
[Music]
oh James is already in the Forbidden
Forest look at him dude
okay wait what's
what's something we could say
well he's in the Forbidden Forest what's
a good message
oh wait
no no follow the spiders
all right let's look for Ivy
we have to go into the castle Corridor
all right
[Music]
I didn't know the castle was so dark at
night
who's there hey watch where you point
that thing oh Robin are you looking for
Ivy as well
right same as you Lottie sent me a note
by Owl
come on we're meeting in the library
everyone is waiting
what is the name of my house I'm uh I'm
in Gryffindor
oh dude look at look at the uh like the
nighttime effects here
the loading is super fast too it's not
open world like Hogwarts Hogwarts Legacy
is this everyone I mean that's on my I'm
playing on my iPhone too
it's super super fast load times
he's over there by the bookshelf on the
first night
if trying to learn things at school is
mad oh wait Daniel's a Gryffindor too
well is everybody ready to look for Ivy
she hasn't returned to the dorm yet so
she must still be lost somewhere in the
castle I guess these are all
automatically in your house I'm guessing
is it safe absolutely not
Caitlyn welcome perfect a whole bunch of
crafts how's it going
they're Ravenclaw okay that's what I was
saying in Jenny that it had to be we
could definitely use someone as clever
as you to help find ivy
oh Jake with another tin
Jake appreciate it so much dude
I've got presents
I need to move that down actually
right there
so you guys can see it appreciate the
Super Chat Jake
yeah you can only have four in the
actual dorm so if you if you're
Gryffindor Jake and you're in then
that's that's it it's you me uh Dylan
and Robo panda in our dorm
all right let's enter
the potions classroom
where are we
a classroom obviously
foreign
oh here we go more spiders
oh the audio is definitely at a slight
delay for what I'm hearing
I don't know if that's what you guys see
too
latest oh let's hit these trolls with an
incendio
are these these trolls these spiders
I'm gonna walk over here
kind of use this table to block
thunderstorms
use the thunderstorm there
so wait are these like companion cards
just I guess they're just free to use
any time
let's hit it with the incendio again
that worked
pretty well
oh that spider's got a lot of help
though look at it
you got PS PS2
I'm not sure what you mean
not the PlayStation 2 right
zodiac I am I'm actually surprised at
how much I'm liking it to be honest with
you
I I did not think
I would be enjoying it this much
I'm still very early
very very early oh we need that troll
I feel like you always need at least one
spell that's gonna be like a good up
close defensive kind of spell
when you get so many like let's go ahead
and get these guys out here to help us
now you're enjoyable
okay wait before we do that let's let's
do the bombs again let's do that trick
they taught us earlier about
doing that and then the monster book
s man there's so many
there we go finally
[Music]
yeah and I mean and it's and it's free
and I've not I mean we'll see how it
goes once I get through the main story
and stuff but to this point like I've
not felt like the need to spend money at
all
you need to be careful or we'll get lost
too what I've heard is that
let me let them finish here
put out that light
excuse me but did you happen to see a
first-year student come through here
tonight
not until this very moment but the next
time Mr fils wanders by I'll tell him I
saw three
[Music]
there's our boy peeves
hang on three only supposed to be one
last little thirsty
we are not lost we're looking for Ivy
oh Your Heroes very Gallant
a metal
Oh wait we're fighting peeves
say what
all right let's get that out and then
very quickly get this troll out
move away from that
all right let's get the lightning going
let's use this on peeves right here
oh dude peeves has a lot of Health
okay we just lost our troll so let's go
ahead and bring him back
and move away move over here oh no no no
move back over here
let's do another inflatus
dude Draco the MVP telling us about uh
how powerful thunderstorm is that's been
clutched so far
foreign
monster book The Monster Book right here
all right we've almost got him down to
halfway
yeah I really need to figure out and I'm
sure this will come in time the more you
play
but like I mean right now I feel like
I'm kind of just constantly throwing out
different spells
but I'm sure as you progress you're
supposed to be
a little bit more strategic about it
like see right now I'm gonna wait I'm
gonna wait and let it build up so I can
use my my lightning right there yeah it
hits a random Target
an Arachnophobia mode for this game I
don't think so
okay let's go with
cindio oh wait he's on the move
okay now let's hit him with that one
I like the atmosphere charm too oh and
the troll just hit him for 168.
how's he not gone his health looks like
it's
empty
fantastic bomb
monster book
how is he not done
there we go
used to be a member oh he used to be a
member here crafts nice thank you for
your support
I just got from P.S
just got from PS2 I'm not sure what the
PS2 means
lost just like you are
Daniel oh my goodness that was way
delayed
I wonder if it's because my phone's
getting so hot will we get caught
Daniel how are you gonna turn Us in like
that dude
greetings from Greece welcome welcome
that thank you for stopping by
strategy is more of a thing in duels and
the Forbidden Forest gotcha
appreciate you guys all being here and
hanging out hope you're enjoying the
stream today I just realized I have it
on
top chat instead of live chat so hope I
haven't missed anybody's messages
I just changed it though
that said keep out
dude I knew Daniel was
person here
oh then what do you call that
what is it I can't see I can fix that
wait why would you want to make it
larger
no
okay wait why did she do in gorgio what
you had to be aiming for something else
right oh wait drag uh drag to someone a
companion each companion card can only
be used once per battle okay
I need to figure out how to change the
order of the companion cards too
troll it's gonna back up a little bit
yeah let's get you
I feel like vintus is really good for
spacing
again I'm very early so
I don't know much about the Battle
system yet
look at the fangs on that monster book
I'd better keep my distance yeah that's
what I'm
on troll
all right let's do inflatus again
oh my gosh this thing is just like
what's the book All Over Me
oh dear we are in trouble
where's Robin
run off of course she's going to get
caught I'm sure of it
whoa
come on let's try this way
uh well later getting to see some of the
castles more unique tapestries
shows learning ballet
I'm trying to think
why are you pacing back and forth helps
me think
the Lost Girl Is Not Gonna magically
appear
not all there before
put your phone in front of a fan Paula
what do you think is in the season oh if
only I had that
[Music]
I don't even have a fan actually
but the setup that we've got going I
would have to have the fan litter it'd
be like blowing right into the uh wait
there she is oh
really
thank you so much I so badly wanted to
be found weird place Why'd You Come here
Avi I don't know this is weird
all I remember is lots of hallways and
stairs and then
I can't be sure but I think someone was
following me
following you
did you see who it was
no
but it felt like someone was always just
behind me looking over my shoulder
I'm probably just being silly bro what
is wrong with this girl
sometime come on Ivy if we can avoid Mr
filch and peeves she's just up here
chilling out like
being here when I came in there are
initials on it ww
W definitely not mine
leave it then let's go
Wizarding World
what is going on
I don't think that's really Ivy man
dude I'm telling you that is not really
ivy
she was acting so strange
amazing deal
join forces with the Whimsical
white-haired witch okay is that Ivy
right there
new student sign in
oh wait is this where we get all our
stuff
daily bonus silver key times one
oh so that's where yeah I see if you
sign in for like seven straight days
you get the random legendary card very
cool
so like tomorrow we'll get this
all right all right all right
I'm falling I'm following
[Music]
whoa what is this a magic pass
guaranteed to receive one of the
following rewards legendary card
oh there's no way this is free though
right like you have to pay for the magic
pass
16 Silver Keys eight gold keys 600 gems
geometric earrings
and
[Music]
ombre
glasses
okay obtained via the deluxe magic pass
oh there we go nice so 9.99 for the
deluxe magic pass
19.99 for the premium
huh interesting and then you get the
premium exclusive that gear that they're
wearing right there okay
oh wait so I do get wait what did I
actually I didn't pay for anything
[Music]
hmm
claim all I mean I'll claim everything I
can get oh I see there's like a free
tier yeah you see there's a free tier on
the top line right there
okay
so you'll still be able to get something
even if you don't
oh well we'll be able to get all that on
top
[Music]
because I kind of want to try and see I
feel like the majority
I don't know I want to see how far I can
go without spending any money
I mean because like Cosmetics I really
don't care about Cosmetics me personally
I know a lot of people do but I feel
like the cards are the big thing that I
will
as I get to later game I might be
frustrated if I can't get them
all right uh join a social club am I not
already in a social club
use the map to quickly go to the Social
Club page
okay Hogwarts
select Social Club
Hogwarts students can quickly make
friends by joining a social club of
their choice oh no here we go
just made in social club events with
other members
oh my goodness
okay so here
here is where we would create ours
Auto join or create yeah I think we're
going to create our social club but I'm
not about to do it on stream right now
not about to do it on stream okay I'm
guessing you cannot join more than one
club either can you
or you know what maybe maybe I should
just make it
make it right here right now and you
guys who want to join in you guys are
here supporting the live stream
you guys would be able to hop in
location not set
house recent tour language
English
houses
imagine if I locked it down to
gryffindors only
oh our slogan
you created it already Dylan
I thought that was just our dorm
uh what server we're on the
oh my gosh there's so many things opalai
right
opalai I believe
we are indeed still live Cloud Roth
we're having a good time with this game
so far
okay hold on let me search for Dylan's
but I kind of I feel like I need to
create one Dylan that I uh
oh my gosh
no matching Club found
I'm just gonna create one
oh it's case sensitive okay
I mean guys the fact that
um there it's limited to 50.
like I feel like it's okay if James and
I both have one
I mean because oh wait but hold on can
we we could can we still do stuff
together though if we're not in the same
can you still like do Forbidden Forest
and all that even if you're not in the
same
what the heck is this thing called I
already forgot
laughs
oh I don't know what to do man
because I don't want to lock myself out
of playing with James but I mean between
both of our
communities like we're gonna have way
more than 50.
yeah I mean but both both servers are
going to be very 50 is not going to be a
problem
filling up
like let's see how many James already
has
if I can get it to pop up here
yeah I mean he's already at 32 out of
50. see he's already he named that one
expect to go one
let's see
oh yeah see Dylan's already got the
house wrecking tour right there House
Targaryen that's so cool
I feel like I should make one though
Dylan shouldn't I so I'm like in charge
of it
or is it even gonna let me
just
dude yo
event Fanatics and chatty crowd
report
oh he can make me in charge
I mean like is there any oh wait contact
captain
message information personal space home
page I mean like I don't know like is
there any is there any reason I would
need to be
like do you have any special controls
Dylan as the uh like as the one over it
I have no idea I mean the fact that you
can like you can change this pretty
easily right
so
North America wait what is this North
America number 104 Social Club oh
there's ranks
oh man we might
we might need to go uh
yeah contact captain
information oh that's cool
and then it shows up right there
there you go I gave you a like Dylan now
you have a one popularity let's go
I just don't want people to get confused
like if they think that's the wrong one
but they should like they should see me
I'm just gonna join this one
we learn as we go if we need to change
it we can change it all right so I just
sent an application you might have to
like accept yeah accept me okay there we
go
all right guys so I guess that means you
have to be in charge of accepting Dylan
maybe that's the deal of it
maybe that's what you'll have to do
go and recruit all right
here we go we're putting it out right
now
anybody in the chat watching if you want
to join here we go right here house rack
and tour
Dylan's gonna be having to accept all of
these requests
permission required yeah good call on
that one wait more Social Clubs okay
yeah and it looks like you can leave
social clubs at any time
nice nice nice
I just hope that it doesn't prevent
I don't know if draco's still in here
but I wonder if it prevents me like
could James and I not play together if
we're not in the same one because if
that's the case that's kind of
unfortunate
like let me go into social right here
like okay let's see house
let's see if I tap on is there anything
I can interact with here
ask a friend
I don't know I'm still just learning as
I go
accidentally Join one it's okay I mean
you can you could looks like you can
leave your the social club you can leave
pretty easily
Social Club log event status and club
members
yeah I'm thinking that you can only
you can only be a member of one battle
line battle line right
battle lines that's gonna be fun though
competing oh I'm co-captain Dylan I see
that it made me co-captain
let's go all right all right all right
Social Club poster oh and it lets me
edit the poster
although you probably already said that
I mean I like the one you have actually
and then you got figures in here
oh this is so crazy man this is so cool
text
well you can even change up the text
there's our slogan
oh no you can actually you can have it
over here I see
and then the font
oh see that's the one you made
oh this is crazy man
Social Club Vlog so that tells you when
we have like new people I guess oh yes
like there's when I submitted my
application
requests
so that's where we would see any new
applications all right
all right now let me get members here so
like if I tap on Robo panda
it's removed
okay that allows us to like kick people
Dylan if they get unruly
you tried searching for it you can't
find it okay it should just be if you oh
I bet we have to be on the same server
too
which we are on the opal eye server yeah
yeah same server
yeah go ahead go ahead guys first come
first served join up join up
you just go into your uh
Social Club area and you search for
house rack into oh wait I can invite you
guys too
oh you guys also have to progress to
that point in the game
you have to progress to that point
or you're already in one so like it says
currently unable to join for expecto
that's probably why
what is the little megaphone right here
all right Rayna I see you there
I think that invited you
JW let's invite you I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna start inviting people
okay Dylan it says you're unable to join
Twigs invite you twigs
oh we need Draco you guys Draco come on
join ours
Draco you know what's up dude
elwin all right Ellen you winning on
ours okay okay
JW all right they're sending you one
and then you guys house I was looking at
yours but it said um it says currently
unavailable
see you right there
thank you for the Super Chat by the way
appreciate it house yeah if it would let
me let me see if I tap on your name yeah
just no luck for some reason
all right I think I sent all of you guys
that were eligible I think I sent all of
you one
William dude Williams already at level
10.
I don't think I hope I'm not spamming
anybody and then I can't remember if we
sent Basha I don't know who Basha is but
Basha I'll send you one too
all right there we go
oh so you can try yeah I'm pretty sure
you have to be on the Opel eye
okay what is this trial period up here
Social Club trial period new Social
Clubs are required to obtain 5 000
contribution within 30 days of their
founding teams that complete the task
within 30 days will pass the
you guys we got a trial
all right Dylan we gotta we if they're
not if they're not uh helping us reach
this
we need active players here man we want
to be top ranked
house rack and tour
we gotta get up to the top
we got Draco let's go
nice Draco
nice uh
I don't even know how we get these
points but we're gonna get them you rest
assured we are going to get them Social
Clubs that failed to complete the trial
period tasks within 30 days will be
disbanded yo they ain't playing around
the items used to create the social club
will be returned to the founder VIA
in-game mail
a day passes in the trial period okay
oh man this is actually kind of cool
so do we get to like is there is there
somewhere where you can see ranks and
stuff
my current ranking 107 my social club
880. I don't even know what that means
but
then you've got region and server
oh my gosh dude I gotta talk to James we
gotta like we gotta do some fun little
uh
we gotta set up some fun competitions
okay wait so server so here is the
server right now mew mew Cafe they
already have 50 members and they're at
twenty thousand sixty six points then
you got Azkaban
oh man all these have 50.
legendary magicians hogsmeade Reapers
you get them by doing team events like
the classrooms and Forest events ah okay
okay okay
GG what's up welcome back actual Pirates
Luna fans
oh it's all in good fun it's all in good
fun
older in Dumbledore hey there's expecto
go they already got 5425 all right
they're at number 38 huffle scuffle
House Targaryen some of these names are
great wizard Hideout D.A
oh this is so fun does it only it
probably only shows like the top 100 or
something
oh no it keeps going
we were what 10109 there we are you guys
880.
880. we got this I don't know why it
only shows one member though
it should show more than that
yeah we got four members now we got
Draco in here too
all right
they were number one oh let's go man
let's go
Gigi you gotta join our club are you are
you in the game yet
so it's basically just like a fun little
uh
how about you describe your social club
oh Draco while you're here so can you
only do Forbidden Forest runs with
people in your social club
or is there there surely there's another
way for me to like go on runs with James
and stuff even if we're in different
Social Clubs
I hope so if not that's going to be very
unfortunate card trade
what is this
exchange cards Social Club Exchange
you're on right now
what was your name did you friend
request me
so you whenever you get to I think you
have to get to a certain point in the
game guys
I think that's why we couldn't invite
house I think you have to progress to
the point where you can um
oh what's it called
when you can when it gives you the
option in game to join a social club
so you need to look for just search out
house rack and tour whenever you get to
that point guys
and we can only take 50 so it's like
first come first served once we hit 50
that's it unless somebody has to get uh
eliminated so like this whole area is
related to Social Club stuff right here
this is cool
talk to mcgonago in the Great Hall
okay wait Draco said
uh I think or Jenny said I think you
joined friends to do things but not with
Team events
oh it kicked you for four hours because
you joined one and then left
ah okay
Elwyn has to level up so she can accept
so you do you have to reach a certain
level and you also have to be in our
server guys the opeli server
both of those
then you have to reach a certain point
oh man but Drago says the team Forest
exploration is just for teams
team and when you say teams you mean the
Social Clubs
oh man that's unfortunate dude
that's unfortunate
you applied okay
oh this is this is awesome how many
times have I said this is awesome
all right let's see details where did I
go I think it was the log
oh I just had it man requests oh it says
no new applications
I don't see you GG I don't see you did
Draco or I did uh
Dylan already accept it maybe
he did there you are
yes
let's go
why am I getting this is just so
exciting man
oh
I don't know why it's so exciting but it
is
oh we got another one another one just
dropped in
JW let's go
I don't know it's like we we had this
whole experience leading up to Hogwarts
Legacy right where we were all you know
we were all looking forward and excited
for that game
I accepted you uh I'm pretty sure that
was Roger who sent that one
it was like a single player experience
so we you know we went off we did our
own thing we played the game we had fun
and then that was it
this though
the fact that we can do all these
activities together we can compete like
each season they're gonna have ranks and
all that
that's fun that is fun
all right
Social Club family tree
yo Dylan see this is why I wanted to be
the founder
Dylan Dylan trying to take the spotlight
here you see
on our on our house wrecking tour family
portrait it's not retro you see at the
top it's our buddy Dylan
oh man that is too funny
one how's it going Juan all right guys
uh this has been a blast man I've got to
get to work on some videos because I
want to make there's several videos that
I want to make for this game
uh let's go ahead and talk to McGonagall
real quick
and then we're gonna hop off but uh yeah
anybody who wants to join house rack and
tour
whenever you get to the Social Club
section that's all you need to do is
type in house wrecking tour we only have
like five members or something right now
well done your performance but 50 is the
cap so once we hit 50 that's it
show us the favorite yeah we gotta
figure out how you change the portrait
that's so funny however that's
I knew there would be something like
that Dylan I knew it
owe me that Hogwarts you must be willing
to challenge yourself okay we're ready
I'll do my best professor
hey sounds good Jenny my first day at
Hogwarts Hogwarts is amazing it's only
been a few days but I've accomplished so
much
urshrobe a wand the owl sorting yes uh
duels 10 locations in the castle I know
15 spells atmospheric charm is probably
my favorite my Spellbook level is now
eight I can't wait to see what
challenges await whatever they are I'll
be ready
tap here to view available story tests
so that's like that was like the
prologue right there I guess we just now
finished it task details will be
displayed here
tap here to be your daily tasks
okay right over here
tap the question mark for more details
wow
all right man it's gonna be a lot of fun
guys we're gonna be doing a lot of
streams for this game so appreciate you
all being here appreciate you all
hanging out hope you all had a good time
on the stream today sorry about the
beginning it took us a little while to
get going but once we got everything up
and running it was nice and smooth so
hope you all enjoyed it stay tuned to
the channel I'm gonna be putting out
some videos with info and more details
about the game so appreciate you all
being here everybody have a great rest
of your day thank you all so much for
watching
and I will talk to you again soon
[Music]